안녕하십니까 채밀턴 여러분. 행복한
투자 예정을 함께하는 체슬리 모닝
브리프 7월 1일 7월 첫 번째 날
일부 시작하겠습니다.
6월 마지막 날 중국 시장 어떻게
마감됐는지 왕정부장님과 함께
알아보겠습니다.
>> 네.
어 어제는 테크주 강세가 지수되면서
상 지수 플러스 0.5% 5%
올라왔고요. 형성책 지수는 1.8%
상승하고 정시 거대면 3정 3조까지
내려왔어요. 업종별 좀 보시면
커뮤니케이션 IT 산업제 업종이 컨셉
배웠고 반면 부동산 금 에너지
이동업제 약세 배웠습니다. 뭐 이분의
허실적 기대감 그리고 저가 매수
자금으로 광동시 업종 어 반등
나왔어요. 종자 우차는 4% 올라고
신 역선는 9% 전부 건통시는
2.6% 전비 건는 3.6% 벗어
올라왔고요. 글로벌 동조화로 반도체
권용 조도 강세 보였어요. 법방
화천은
최근날 매일매일 올라가고 있습니다.
법화천 어제는 2.8% 올라고 종이
반도체는 2.6%
전승테크는 1% SMS는 5%
한국기는 7% 올라왔어요. 2차 정지
관련주도 이틀 연속 반등했습니다.
C티어는 염증 2% 입보 에너지 염.
7% 양공는 플러스 2% 적어 주시는
2% 상승했습니다. 어 최근에 조정
받았던 PCB 관용수 어세도
올라갔습니다. 동생 청밀력 5% 허전
중심 8% 선루는 5% 올라왔어요.
어 PCB 대규뭐 정찰 대충는 올래
하반기 내년 내 후년까지는 계속
이어질 수 가능성이 있고요.
>> 그래서 PCP 정비 관련주도 어세또
강세포였어요. 대주 레이저는 6%
올라왔고요. 대주 소금 괜찮아요.
5% 올라왔습니다. 화공는 4등
샘퍼스 올라왔어요. 휴먼 로봇
권영수가 어제 또 오랜만에 반등
나왔어요. 어 사마 지구는
6.2%으로 은 2%으로 하고요.
타보클름은 7% 유비테크는 7%으로
하습니다.
에너지 금융주도 이런 방어주들이 여는
상대적인 부진의한 모습을 보였어요.
배터너는 마스 2.7% 신호펜는
-3% 빠졌어요.
신염물 그리고 2년물 금리는 어제
대비는 다 올라왔습니다. 외양화
확률는 또 거의 염증. 1, 4%
잘성되었습니다.
>> 음. 한국은 제가 대략적으로 코스피
코스닥 증시 거래대금이 얼마 정도가
평균치다. 머릿속에 대략 그림이
있는데 중국은 어 거래대금은 매일
말씀을 주시는데 오늘 3.3조 위하는
높은 수준 아니라고 말씀 주셨는데
[콧방귀]
>> 어느 정도가 평균일까요? 아, 평균는
올해 2024년 골 그 시장 급등하기
전에 걸레금은이 절반 수준 밖에
없어요. 1조 정도 됩니다. 아,
>> 그럼 상당히 높은 수준으로 올라가
있는 거네.
>> 네, 맞아요. 계속 높아 높아지고
있고요. 뭐 얘 3,증, 5조 하면은
되게 높은 수준예요. 최근에 높으니까
3조 이상 하면은 곤한 수준입니다.
>> 음. 음. 한국은 그 상장되어 있는
증권 회사들 보면 어 이런
거래대금에서 나오는 수수료가 회사
수입의 상당 부분인 증권사도 있고
>> 아비나 뭐 다른 부분들이 훨씬 더 큰
회사들도 있는데 중국도 그렇겠죠.
>> 네. 네. 맞습니다.
>> 그러면 중국도 어 거래대금이 비즈니스
모델인 증권사들은 주가가 좋습니까?
어
걸로 상대적으로 좋지 않아요. 이유가
그 반도체 됩니다.
>> 음
>> 예 그 [목을 가다듬음] 그리고이
홀산을 이단 지수가 거래당금 계속
높은 수준 유지하고 있지만 지수는
몰라가지 못했어요. 상 지수 좀
보시면 영소 대비 3% 올라왔어요.이
성 지수는 거의 두 자리수 올라가면은
정원주 그때는 올라갈 수 있는데 지수
올라가지 못하지만 거래대 올라가고
있고 멀티브게 주지 못해요.
>> 음. 우리 일별 시황을 보는 날이지만
아 시간이지만 그래도 중국은 상해
지수 CSI 300 대략적으로 지수의
ROE가 어느 정도 돼요?
>> 전혀 모르네.
>> 지수 ROE는
>> 음
>> 원래 우리가 장기적으로는 ROE만큼
지수도 올라갈 수 있다. 이렇게
추정해 볼 수 있는 건데요.
>> 네. 제가 대충는 아마 10%는 미만
수준이고요.
>> 음.
>> 네. 그러면 증권은 중국의 ROE가
올라올 때를 기다려야 하나 이런
>> 파생적 생각까지도 좀 해 봅니다.
네. 알겠습니다. 여쭤봤던 이유가
그저께 코스닥이 상당히 그 코스피랑
차별화를 보이면서 급등했는데
>> 어 이제 일관 시황을 좀 이렇게 쭉
보다 보니까 거래량을 동반하지 않았기
때문에 그냥 단기적인 반등으로 보는게
맞지 않겠느냐라는 말씀들을 많이 해
주셔서
>> 중국은 거래대금이 동반이 [콧방귀]
되고 이제
>> 어 파왕의 어떤 징표를 사용할 수
있는데 그 레벨이 어느가 좀
궁금했습니다. 우리가 그러면 앞으로
3조한 이상이라고 왕부장님이 체크해
주시면 중국 시장은 거래대금은 상당히
좀
>> 높게 잘 나오고 있구나라고 이해해도
됩니까?
>> 네, 맞습니다.
>> 기준점을 잡고 가겠습니다.
>> 이슈 종목 보겠습니다. 설명해 주신
적 있는 거 같은데요. 더 주식.
맞습니다.이
죽광연
인버터 제조 홀사이고요. 글로벌 시장
MS는 1등 유지하고 있고 동남마
시장 MS 60% 증사 해외 매출
비중는 거의 80% 정도 되고요.
1번기 실전은 저한테 나왔어요. 뭐
매출에는 동기 대비 73.8%
증가하고 Q는 32% 순위는 동의.
4% 44% 증가했습니다. 지장 대충
보 보안 수준 나오고요. GP
마진율이 41.45%로
동기 대비 4.2% 화대하고요. MP
마진률은 22.25% 나왔습니다.
동의포하라 했어요.
>> 네. 어 유럽 종동 동남아 지역s
수요 하우저에 따라서 인버터 등 제품
매출는 거승 지수되고 있고요. 단
환차순 발성으로 어 수익 인률을
소포하라 했습니다. 1분는 ES
인버터 출학 동대비 100%
급정했어요. 어 배터리 100 동의
대비는 20 260% 정도
급정했습니다. 정년 마르키지 ES
인버터 GP 마진는 52.1%
나오고요. 태양권 인버터는 32.1%
1% 이해 배터리 패는 GP 마진는
32.8% 8% 나왔어요.
어 현재는 공전은
다 풀가동이에요.
거의 나가는 물량 다 나갔습니다.
가격 인상 그리고 케파 추가 증
가능성도 있어요. 1분기에 가격은
인상했습니다. 3월프는 마지는
개선되었고 어 5월도 추가적으로 가격
인상했어요. 그래서 2분기에 아마 뭐
실정 좀 기대할 수 있을 가능성이 좀
있습니다. 시장 컨소스 분면은 2번기
순위는 전기 전분기 대비는 10%부터
20% 증가 예상이고요. 이포단은
좋게 나오면은 아마 주가는 한번
점프할 가능성도 있습니다. 어제 나온
리포드 좀 보면은 어 그럴 수요 호조
ASP 가격 인상 케파 정찰등로 매수
위험을 제시했습니다. 올해 보다 내년
내 후년 수 있는 각유 외한 72억
82억 외한을 추정되었고 동기 대비는
75% 27% 20% 증가
추정되었습니다.
역산호 하면은 원래 예산피아는
어 24배 중 되고요. 내년은 19배
내 후년은 15배 밖에 없습니다.이
>> 호전는 부는 타켄은 20일부터 25배
정도 받을 수 있고요. 그래서 내년
기중을 하면 25배 PR 적용하면 어
TP는 139 외 가능성이 있습니다.
어제 전가 대비 30% 없애면 나올
수 있어요. 저는 잘 모르는 종목이라
기업이라
>> 어이 회사는
인버터를 만드는 회사인데
>> 네
>> 전방 산업이 주거용
>> 주거용요
>> 그러면 주거용이라면
일반적인 주택 아파트 아니면
>> 맞요 주택 아파트 쪽으로 말
>> 주택 아파트 여기 주거형 과호 상업용
상업용이라고 써 주신 이유는 공장도
생각하시면
>> 공장도
>> 그러면 우리가 덕업 주식 자체를
투자하려면 이제 저희가 투자할 때 뭐
이익질 그 회사의 어 마켓의 어떤
성장성 이런 것들을 보는데이
>> 회사의 전방 산업은 그러면 주택
시장인가요? 어, 주택 시전을 보시면
됩니다. 왜냐면 주택 시전은 특히는이
회사가 거의 물련은 다 해외 무련
있잖아요. 그래서이 해외는 어떤
상황인지는 잘 봐야 되고요.
>> 왜냐면 2, 3년 전에 그 율업
쪽으로는 전기 가격은 급등했잖아요.
그때는 ESG 그 임포터 그 부산을
시점을 대봐놨어요.
>> 그 이유가 있습니다. 왜냐면 전기
가격 올라가면은 반사 이해받을 수
있어요.
>> 음.
>> 예. 그리고 전가스 가격으로 하면은
또 반자이 받을 수 있고요. 정력
공급 공급이 쇼티지 나올 수 있으면은
거기서는 최대수해 줍니다.
>> 그래서 최근에음
뭐
>> 종동 지역 리스크도 생기고 그리고 뭐
그 유럽 날씨도 덥잖아요 지금.
그래서 최근에 기사 보니까 유럽
지역은 에어컨 부매는 확대하고
있어요.
>> 음.
>> 그래서 이런 거 생각하면은 ES
인버터는 아마도 합쳐서 뭐가 수액을
받을 수 가능성이 있습니다.
>> 음. 그래서 주로 유럽 시장 그 정체
좀 봐야 되고요. 요즘에 유럽 시전은
유럽 정부는 계속 뭐 관세포가 이런
거 얘기가 나오고 있어요. 그래서
최근에 주관을 좀 전혀 바았습니다.
다만이 호의사는 가성비 제일 좋은
제품을 만들고 있잖아요.
>> 음.이
>> 관세 보가 되면 정세 정체 그 비용당
우리 알 수 있어요.이
>> 전부 구매할 때 가격 구매할 때
>> 그래서 약간 또 피해가 바을 수
있어요.
>> 음. 뭐 장기 관증하면은 별 의미가
없다고 생각하고 그래서 이런 회사는
실전은 우상향 지수되면서 주가로
따라서 올라갈 수 있다고 생각해요.
>> 음. 네. 말씀 처음에 들었을 때는
집을 새로 지을 때 수요가
있겠구나라고 생각했는데 물론 그런
수요도 있겠습니다만
>> 어 원래 그냥 기존에 살던 집에서
교체 수요가 있을 수도 있고
그렇겠네요.
>> 네, 맞습니다.요
>> 밑에 2025년 기준s 인버터 GPM
어 태양광s용
뭐 이렇게 말씀해 주신 거는 그냥요
산업별로의 GPM이지 이게 매출
비중은 아니에요.
>> 아 매출 비중 아닙니다. 네.
>> 절대적으로 지금은 주거형 쪽으로
>> 맞습니다.
>> 집중이 되어 있는 회사인 거
같습니다.
>> 어, 전 세계 주택 시장, 건설 시장
이런 것들을 이제 전방 산업으로 하고
있기 때문에
>> 어, 건설 경기가 좋아지고 그럴 때
어느 회사가 앞으로 수주를 더 많이
하고 공사를 많이 하지 이런게 좀
고민스러울 때
>> 덕업 주식 인버터를 쓰겠다. 이런
생각으로이 회사에 투자하면 좀 더
안전할 수도 있겠습니다.
>> 음, 맞습니다. 네.
밸루에이션들이 돼 보니까 상대적으로
밴드를 뚫고 가고 그러는 종목은
아니니까 관심 종목에 넣어두고
하겠습니다. 중국 시장 여기까지
보겠습니다. 다음은 전일 미국 시장
6월 마지막 날을 어떻게 마무리했는지
요리프로와 함께 보겠습니다.
>> 네. 어 어제 미국장 말씀드리도록
하겠습니다. 우선 어 AI랑 반도체가
다시 시장 끌어올리면서 어제 이제
마감한 2월 30일 미국장 이거래일
연속 상승하면서 마감을 했습니다.
아무래도 어제 또 짚어드렸듯이
상반기랑 2분기를 마무리하는
장이었는데요. SP랑 라스닥 같은
경우에는 2022년 이후로 가장 강한
분기 성과를 기록했다고 합니다. 그럼
2022년이란요 지표가 그래서 뭘까?
또 부연 설명을 드리면 2022년
2분기 때는 뭐 코로나가 있었죠.
정책
반등
다만 이번에 다른 점은 뭐 AI랑
반도체가 이제 핵심 테마인만큼 그런
투자 사이클 그리고 경기 회복력이
만든 실적 기대라라는 점에서 좀
성격이 다르다. 하지만 이제 가장
최고의 이제 성과를 기록한 어
상반기로 이제 마감을 했다라고
말씀드릴 수 있을 것 같습니다.
그래서 뒤에도 오늘 계속 말씀드릴게이
반도체가 어떻게 끌어올리고 있는지
앞으로 지금 하반기를 볼 때도 이제요
반도체라는 테마가 얼마나 중요할지에
대해서 좀 강조를 해 드릴 거 같아서
요런 식으로 이제 상반기 성과를 먼저
말씀을 드렸고요. 그래서 아래로
이동하셔서 주요 지수부터
보시겠습니다. 우선 주요 지수 중에는
다 다오 지수랑 러셀 2천이 신고가를
기록을 했습니다. 다 같은 경우에는
0.26%
% 이제 상승하면서 52,000포인트
대에서 사상 최고 종가로 기록을
했고요. 이제 금리 민간중소형주
러스리천도 이제 4거래 연속 상승을
하면서 연속 신고가 흐름이어갔습니다.
좀 계속 강한 분기 성과했던 SP랑
나스닥도 언급을 드려야 되는데요 두
지수 같은 경우에는 6월 중순의 고점
뭐 아직 완벽히 넘어선 상태는 아니긴
하지만 S&P 500 같은 경우에도
0.79% 79% 상승하면서
7,500선 좀 근접을 했고 나스닥
종합 지수 같은 경우에도 1.52%
상승하면서 주요 지수들 중에서 이제
가장 강하게 반등을 했습니다.
또 어제 상반기 마지막이었던만큼 분기
성과도 제가 간단하게 이제 정리를
아래쪽 텍스트를 해 봤는데 함께 짚어
보면 좋겠으면
좋겠는데 분기 기준으로 보시면 S&P
500 같은 경우에는 2분기에 한
14.9% 9% 상승했고 나스닥
21.4% 4% 상승을 했더라고요.
그래서 상반기 초반에는 장초반 그
연초에 생각을 해 보시면 지정학적
리스크 1장 2월 달에 있었고
그러면서 이제 동반일 금리 부담,
유가 부담 등이 겹치면서 변동성이
상당히 이제 큰 상반기였습니다. 다만
이제 뭐 미국이나 이란의 긴장이 좀
완화되고 그리고 칩이랑 메모리가 계속
AI라는 테마 안에서 계속 랠리를
이어가고 또 견조한 기업 실적 기대가
계속 뭐 전망이 되고 있다라고 말씀해
주시고 있어서 이런 세 가지 지표가
맞물리면서 이제 하반기에도 강한
흐름이 이어질 수 있지 않을까 예상해
볼 수 있을 것 같습니다. 또
짚어드렸듯이 이번 반등 중심 다시
이제 반도체였는데요. 필라델피아
반도체 지수 필반 지수부터 보시면
최근에 고점 대비해서 한 10% 가량
조정을 받았었거든요. 근데 어제 하루
한 3.9% 이제 기재했듯이
급등하면서 이제 하락한 낙폭 상당
부분 되돌렸습니다. 분기 기준으로도
보면 80% 정도 이제 넘게 오르면서
사실상 최고의 분기 성과를
기록했습니다.
종목별로도 보시면은 어떤 도체 쪽에
샌디스크가 어제 되게 강하게
올랐는데요. 11% 가량 상승했고
이제 장비 테스트주 KL 그리고
테라다인 같은 경우에도 강하게 상승을
했고 어제 CPU 종목들이 좀
올랐습니다. AMD가 7.7% 그리고
마베이 극가 많이 하락해 있었는데
7.4% 그 온 세미 컨덕터도
6.7% 7% 가량 상승을 했습니다.
그리고 반도체 장비들도 강했고 이제
52주 신고카 쪽에는 뭐 안페올,
아리스타, 시에나 같은 데이터 센터,
네트워크, 인프라 기업들까지도 동반
상승하면서 그간의 하락분을 좀
되돌리는 움직임 보였습니다.
>> 어, 이제 그 AMD나 인텔 같은
경우에 CPU 종목들이 주목받았다라고
말씀을 드렸는데요. 어제 특별한 기업
이슈가 있었던 건 아니었는데 이제
웰스파고 같은 경우에 AMD의 목표
주가 상향 리포트가 있었습니다.
그래서 AMD 목표 주가를 지금
505달러에서 615달러를 상향을
했는데 뭐 이유인 즉은 뭐 에이전틱
AI라는 키워드였습니다. 뭐 수요
확산에 따른 서버 CPU 성장 기대다
그러면서 AI가 이제 기업 업무
자동화랑 클라우드 인프라로 확산되는
되면은 GPU뿐만이 아니라
CPU라든지 메모리 그리고 전력 관리
반도체까지 이제 동반상 필요하다라는
논리면서 AI 관련된 이제
인프라주들이 동반 상승하는 이제
모양세 보였습니다. 또 52주 신고가
이제 정말 가끔 등장하긴 했는데 뭐
안 패널 같은 경우에도 어제 5.9%
상승을 했거든요. 그래서이 기업 같은
경우에는 뭐 데이터 센터 커넥터
그리고 네트워크 인프라 수웨로 같이
묶어서 설명을 할 수 있을 것
같습니다. 그또 캐터 필러도 52주
싱각 쪽에 이름 올렸는데 이제 데이터
센더 전력이나 건설 인프라 쪽
관련해서 주목을 받고 있는 좀
구산업제 기업이긴 하지만 이제 데이터
센터랑 엮어지면 다 함께 상승한다라는
측면에서 좀 이런 AI 인프라주
그리고 산업제 쪽 경기 민간주에도
일부 매수세가 계속 확산되고 있는
모양세 보였습니다. 그래서 어제 반체
반듯 뭐 필반 지수가 낮고 되돌렸다
정도일뿐만 아니라 장비랑 CPU,
데이터 센터, 이프라까지 뭐 52주
신고가가 확산된 장이었다라고 해석해
볼 수 있을 것 같습니다. 그 텍스트
쪽도 보시면은 경제 지표 예상보다 더
강했습니다. 제 5월 돌트 9인권수가
나왔는데요. 이제 759만
4,000원권 나오면서 시장 예상치를
좀 상의했습니다. 그리고 또 6월
시카고 PMI 지수도 나왔는데
56.7로 7로 나오면서 예상치였던
상의하면서 고형과 제조업 심리가 모두
예상보다 견조하게 나왔다. 그래서 어
다시 한번이 미국 경제 둔화보다는
기업 이익과 그리고 AI 투자 사이클
지속 가능성에 더 무게를 주면서
위험자 선호를 좀 뒤파침하는
상황이었습니다. 다만 좀 주목해 볼
만한 이슈로는 이제 채권 시장
쪽이었는데요. 지금 국채 10년물에서
금리가 좀 크게 올랐습니다. 이제
중간부 우측 보시면 미국 10년물
국채 금리가 9비b비P 가량 상승을
해서 4.47%까지 올라왔습니다.
2년물 같은 경우에는 4.17%
그리고 기재해 드리진 않았지만
30년물이 4.9%까지 이제
올라갔습니다. 그래서이 미국 국채
금리가 전반적으로 올랐는데 이제 특히
이제 10년물이랑 30년물 같은 장기
금리가 인물보다 더 크게 올랐거든요.
그래서 뭔가 매크로 큰 이슈가
있었다기보다는 뭐 강한 경제 지표
그리고 국채 수급 부담이 함께 작용한
결과로 보입니다. 응찰이나 이쪽을 좀
살펴봤었는데 최근에 13주물이 한
920억 달러 뭐 26주물이 790억
달러 6주물이 한 800억 달러 정도
규모의 단기 국제 입찰이 있었거든요.
근데 특히 이제 13주물이랑 6주물
응찰이 이전보다 낮아졌습니다. 음
>> 그래서 그러면서 국제 공급 부담도 좀
일부 반영된 결과로 보입니다. 뭐
여러 가지 숫자로 말씀드리긴 했는데
쉽게 말하면 이제 공급은 많았는데
위험자선 선순 선호가 강해지면서 채권
수요는 이전보다 약했고 그 결과 국제
가격이 내려가고 금리는 올랐다라고 봐
주시면 될 거 같습니다.
>> 외환 시장도 어제부터 살짝 짚어드려서
말씀을 드리면 외환 시장에서 달러가
소폭 강세로 보였고요. 이제 N화는
달러당 162N 후반까지 이제
나오면서 어제 짚어드렸던요
160엔이라는 수치 정부 개입하는
수치의 수준까지 이해 가면서 좀 엔화
약세를 이어갔습니다. 국제 유가는 또
하락을 했는데요. WTI 배럴당
70달러 암 브랜드는 73달러
부근으로 내려왔습니다.
그 업종별로도 위쪽 이동해서 보시면은
이제 기술 자 ID 쪽이 2.5%
상승하면서 시장을 주도했고 산업제도
좀 1.35% 오르면서 상승세를
주도했습니다.
네. 반면에 부동산이나 뭐 유틸리티
필수 소비자의 약세 보이면서 금리
상승 부담이 방어주랑 금리 민감
업종에는 좀 부담으로 작용한 반면에
인프라랑 경기 민감 업정에는 좀
매수세가 이어진 사항이었습니다.
기업단 뉴스 그래도 좀 짚어 드리는게
좋을 것 같아서 하단에 간단해 기재를
해 드렸는데요. 뭐 지수 방향을 크게
바꿀 만한 대형 이벤트는 사실 없기는
했었 제한적이긴 했거든요. 아마 이제
AI가 이제 실제 산업 현장으로
확산되고 있는 좀 흐름들이 보여지면서
간단하게 말씀드리고자 하는데 이제
앤트로픽이 과학 연구형 AI 워크
벤치인클로 science스라는 이제
제품을 공개했습니다. 뭐 최근 뭐
AI 인프라에 좀 막대한 자금이
들어가고 있는데 그럼 이제 생각해 볼
점은 결국이 최종 투자 투자의 최종
수요차가 어떻게 돈을 벌 수 있을지를
생각을 해 봐야 되거든요. 이제 그럴
경우에요 클로즈 사이언스라는 이제
소프트웨어가 과학 연구랑 신약 개발
같은 점은 R앤D 영역으로 더 이제
사용할 수 있다라고 하면서 요런 이제
특수한 영역으로도 AI가 확산되는
흐름이 있다라는 점 한번 짚어 볼 수
있을 것 같습니다. 그래서 그 외에
이제 빅테크 쪽 뉴스로는 애플의 뭐
에픽 게임스 관련 항소를 미국
대법원이 심리학기로 했다는데 핵심은
뭐 앱스토어 외부 결제 뭐 유도 제한
그리고 수술 체계가 다시 이제 대거원
재판 때 오른 거라서 뭐이 결과에
따라서 향후 이제 애플의 플랫폼 수익
모델 그리고 빅테크 관련돼서 규제
논의 다시 좀 불을 붙일 수 있지
않을까 정도로 보입니다. 네. 그리고
뒷부분에 아마 어 간단하게 말씀드실
수도 있을 것 같은데 뭐 비자나
스트라이프 그 BNI 멜론 같은
금융사들이 좀 뭐 그 스테이블 코인
이니슈티브에 참가하면서 스테이블
코인이 뭐 결제랑 금융 인프라 쪽으로
더 확장되는 흐름도 확인됐다. 그래서
기업단 이슈에서는 전반적으로 돈이
쓰이고 있는 곳에 있어서 수위처들이
조금씩 확인되고 있고 미국 경제
자체도 굉장히 견조하게 더 유동성을
확보하는 쪽으로 나아가고 있다 정도로
이제 인식해 주시면 될 거 같습니다.
>> 네. 그래서 정리드리면 어제 미국장
뭐 AI 인프라 랠리가 더 넓어진
장이었고요. [목을 가다듬음] 그래서
이제 반도체 같은 경우에는 뭐
메모리부터 이제 전력 반도체까지 같이
오르고 고용과 제조업 지표가 경기
회복력을 강하게 이제 확인시켜 줬다.
다만 10년물 금리가 좀
4.47%까지 올라온만큼 이제 상반기
마무리하고 하반기에는요 AI
[목을 가다듬음] 기대감이 실제
매출이나 이익 현금으로 얼마나 이제
더 빠르게 많이 꽂칠지가 중요해질
것으로 보입니다. 이상입니다.음
>> 감사합니다.
보통 저희가 오르는 지수가 상승할 때
오르는 종목의 수가 많을수록 어
시장이 좀 퀄리티가 좋다고 보통
얘기를 많이 하는데요 전보다는 좀
그래도 오르는 종목의 범위가 좀
넓어진 거 같아요. 그런 부분 어제
좀 좋았던 거 같고
>> 말씀 주셨을 때 올해 2분기 동안
SP 500이랑 나스닥이 각각
14.9% 21.4% 4% 올랐다고
어 정리해 주셨는데 위에 연간 오은
것과 비교해 보면 그럼 1분기는 SP
500 나스닥 전부 다 마이너스를
기록했을 거예요.
>> 네. 어 올해 초말 요때 2026년도
미국 시장을 전망했던 자료들을 볼 때
어 2024년 5년이 워낙에 좀
강하게 올라왔기 때문에 보통 이런
경우에는 3년 차에도 올라간다.
그런데 올라갈 확률이 높은 건 맞는데
굉장히 어 그 영어식으로 표현하면
헌피범피 그래서 이게 좀 변동성 있게
올라간다고 얘기를 했는데 어 분기별로
이렇게 따박따박 올라가지 않고 세
달이면 결코 적은 기간이 아닌데
1분기는 좀 하락 많이 했다가 2분기
걸도 다 메이크업하고 더오르고 이제
이런 시장을 봐서는
시장의 컬러가 상승 3년차 장이다라는
것을 상반계 증명을 한 것 같고 빅
빅 M7 7 뭐 빅테크요 종목들
중에서 SMP 500보다 많이 오른
종목은 결과적으로 구글 그니까 알파벳
이외는 없는 거 같습니다. 그래서
M7 이외에 반도체 중심으로
[목을 가다듬음]
어 종목들 확산과 추도주가 확실히
1년 차 2년 차는 좀 다르다라는
생각도 해 봤습니다. 오늘도 우리
유류가 완벽하게 요약을 해 주셔서
정리가 [목을 가다듬음] 쏙쏙 잘 된
거 같습니다. 미국 시장 여기까지
보겠습니다. 가상 자산으로 넘어가서
준역 주임과 함께 하겠습니다.
네. 가장 시장 말씀드리겠으만
말씀드리겠습니다. 차트 보시면
아시겠지만 가격은 굉장히 안
좋습니다. 어제 6만 물 정도를
지켜주는 흐름 보여줬었는데 어
스트레티지가 그 다섯
[목을 가다듬음] 개의 프레임워크를
발 그 발표를 한게 좀 단기적인
이슈였다라는 거를 조금 증명하는 어제
흐름이었다라고 보시면 될 거 같고요.
아까 말씀 주신 것처럼 10년물
장기, 10년 장기물이 올랐기 때문에
어 단기적으로 좀 그어 압박을 좀
받는 부분도 있을 거고 지금 N화가
지금 굉장히 약세로 가고 있습니다.
그렇기 때문에 NK캐리 트레이드
청산에 대한 우려도 지속적으로 지금
비트코인 가격을 누르고 있는게 아닌가
하는 생각을 하고 있고요. 지금 가장
큰 화두는 스트레티지이기 때문에
스트레티지 이슈가 조금 어 진정될
때까지는 어 계속해서 비통 가격이 안
좋을 수 있다. 그래서 한 5만
2,000불, 5만 불 정도까지는
열어도 생각을 하는게 좀 마음이 편할
것 같다라고 말씀드릴 수 있을 것
같고요. 그래서 오른쪽에는 비트코인
장기 차트 보시게 되면 한 5만
58,불 정도 구간을 아
58,000불 정도 구간을 유지하고
있기 때문에이 구간이 한 5만 불
정도 열려 있다라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 지금 엔드인데 보시면
극단적 공포 구간에 있고요. 한 15
정도를 기록하고 있기 때문에 내일이
된다라고 하면이 수치가 좀 더
나아지지 않을까 하는 생각을
[목을 가다듬음] 개인적으로 하고
있고 오른쪽에 비트코인 현물 ETF
순위 승유출 보시면 230년 정도가
월요일 날 유출이 됐습니다. 그래서
유출세가 멈출 줄을 모르고 계속해서
유출이 되고 있기 때문에 ETF
쪽에서 계속해서 빠져나가고 있다.
그러면 그러면 이제 스트레티지가 좀
이제 약간 매수를 해 줘야 되는데
스트레티지도 지금 어 이슈가 있기
때문에 어 좀 매수를 못 해 주고
있는 상황이다. 그렇게 되면 비트코인
가격이 약세가 될 수밖에 없다를
말씀을 드릴 수가 있을 것 같습니다.
그리고 원래 내일 간단하게 정해서
말씀드리려고 했는데 아까 그 어
다양한 뭐 비자나 마스터카드 다양한
기업들이 스테이블 코인을 발행 그
발행해서 어 유통시키겠다라고 하는 그
계획을 발표를 했는데요. 어 저는
그래서 어제 서클이 한 18% 정도
빠졌습니다. 저는 개인적으로 생각했을
때는이
그 먼저 선점하는 [목을 가다듬음]
사람들이 무조건 유리하다고 생각을
하거든요. 그래서 서클이 지금 어
물론 USDT 테더보다는 점유율이
훨씬 떨어지는 부분은 인정을 하고
맞다라고 생각하 하고 있지만 결국
미국 네이티브 어 스테이블 코인의
서클이 그냥 가장 우세입니다. 그리고
미국 쪽 그리고 제도권에 올라 있는
스테이블 코인은 무조건 USDC가
가장 압도적으로 유리하거든요.
그래서이 점유율을 뺏어오는 과정에서의
밸루에이션 저란 조금 있을 수 있지만
단기적으로 그럴 수 있지만
장기적으로는 어 무조건 USDC가
유리할 수밖에 없는 환경이다라고
말씀드릴 수 있을 것 같고 어 이게
다양한 주체들이 또 엮겨 있다 보니까
또 그 제도권 안에 있는 그런 룰들을
다 지키면서 가야 될 확률이 굉장히
큽니다. 근데 서클은 지금 USDC만
하고 있는 그런 회사이 있기 때문에
어 장기적으로 무조건 서클이 더
유리할 것 같다라는 의견을 드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다. 주일 첫 번째
보시면 어 스트레티지가 어제 큰
발표를 하나 했는데 어제 간단하게
말씀드리면서 좀 구체적으로 설명 한번
드리려고 하셨습니다. 어 늦었지만
생존을 위한 선택 루나인가 피봇인가
이렇게 제가 제목을 지어봤는데요.
스트리티지가 2월 29일 날 회사
입장에서 좀 역사적인 결정을
내렸습니다. 원래 스트레티지는 어
자금을 조달해서 비트코인을 그냥 무한
매수를 하게 되는 그런 회사의 사업
구조를 가지고 있었는데요. 어이
루나테라 구조를 제가 한번 간단하게
말씀을 드리면 될 거 같습니다. 여기
UST 그리고 프로토콜 루나 이렇게
세 가지가 나와 있는데요. 어이
이거는 지금 무조건 1달 1불의
패깅이 되어 있는 겁니다. 그래서
UST 그니까 이렇게 스테이블 코인이
1달러를 하회하게 된다라고 하면 루나
그러니까 반대편에 루나를 팔아서
UST를 사서이 과치를 다시 회복시켜
주는 그런 구조가 형성이 되어
있거든요. 그래서 이런 구조가 깨졌을
때 어 좀 데드 스파이를 나올 수
있는 그런 그 구조로 형성이 되어
있었습니다. 근데 이게 사람들이 그냥
직접 사고파는게 아니라 알고리즘적으로
직접 사고 팔았기 때문에이 구조적
허점을 이용한 어 사태가 2022년에
발생했다. 이렇게 흐름을 보시면 될
거 같고요. 어이 흐름 자체가 이해는
안 될 수 있지만 어쨌든 양쪽에 있는
것을 밸런스를 맞추려고 한쪽 가치가
떨어졌을 때 반대편 팔아서 채워줬다.
이렇게 해석을 하시면 될 것
같습니다. 그리고 3D지가 디지털
크레드 캐피럴 어 프레임워크라는 것을
어 발표를 했는데 여기에는 현금 연구
우선주인 STIC 그리고 STRC 그
MSTR과 어 STC 자사주 메이
프로그램 그리고 그 비트코인의 관리
정책 및 계획을 포함했다라고 보시면
될 거 같습니다. 다섯 가지인데요.
하나하씩 간단하게 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 첫 번째 현금
계획이었습니다. 지금 스트레티지가 어
ATM을 굉장히 많이 발행을 해서
거의 시가 총이 20%가 날아갔다라고
보시면 될 거 같고 희석이 됐습니다.
어 그래서 지금 보유 보유하게 되는
현금이 한 2.255 빌리언 정도가
됐다라고 보시면 될 거 같고요. 현재
잔존하는 오른쪽에 보시면 잔존하고
있는 부채가 한 6빌년 정도가 되게
됩니다. 그래서 6빌년 정도가 아직
계속해서이자 비용을 어 충당하게 되는
그런 비용으로 남아 있다라고 보시면
될 거 같고요. 어 그리고 현재
준비금이 2.5빌리언 모빌리언 정도가
되는데이 자금은 오직 우선주 및 아
우선주 배당급 및 부채이자 지급에만
쓸 수 있고 다른 용도를 위해서는
이사의 승인이 필요하다라는 정책기를
발표를 했고요. 지금 최소 12개월치
커버리지를 유지하는 것으로 결정이
됐다라고 합니다. 그래서 최근에 제가
그 보여 드린 커버리지 표를 봤을 때
이게 12개월보다 떨어지는 그런 그
커버리지 그 곡선이 훅 떨어지는 그런
걸 저희가 한번 보여 드린 적이
있었는데 그걸 좀 최소 12월
12개월 12개월치는 좀 유지하는
그런 결정을 내렸다라고 보시면 될 거
같고요. 그래서이 12개월치보다
내려가기 위해서는 별도 이상의
2사회의 승인이 필요하다고 합니다.
그 지금 현재 명간 배당과이자 비용을
따졌을 때 한 1.8년 정도가 되니까
현금을 무조건 1.8빌리 8년 정도는
무조건 유지를 하겠다라는 발표를 한
거다라 보시면 될 거 같고요. 그래서
비트코인을 매각을 할 계획을 이따 그
밑에서 발표를 그 말씀 한번
드리겠지만 그 매각을 통한 자금
1.25빌리언 추가 자금 요달 어
1억까지 합치게 된다라고 하면
3.8빌리언 정도까지는 우리가 확충해
둘 수 있다라고 시장을 좀
안정시켰다라 보시면 될 거 같고요.
어 밑에 내려와서 보시면 두 번째는
STRC의 배당 정책을 발표를 해
줬습니다. 어 26년 7월 1일부터
배당률을 또 인상을 했는데요.
12%로 인상이 했습니다. 액면과
근처인 99불에서 100불 범위로
거래되고 하는 것이 목표다라고 제가
하이라이트를 쳐놨는데이 부분이 어
제가 루나 테러랑 비슷한 거 아닌가
하는 생각을 하게 된 어 계기입니다.
목표이며 그리고 비트코인 가격 시장
분위기 차세 자금 상태를 보고 어 그
STIC 배당을 결정하겠다라고 발표를
해줬고요. 그래서 무조건적으로 지금
100불 액면 회기를 목적으로 지금
뭐 90%을 어 떨어질 때마다
배당률을 인상하다가 지금 12%까지
오게 된 건데 그런 목적에 배당률
인상은 좀 멈추겠다는 의미로 해석이
시장에서 됐기 때문에 어 시장했기
됐기 때문에 주주 환원에서 조금 더
좋은 것이 아닌가 하는 의미에서 어제
그 MSTR과 스 그 STIC가
가격이 조금 올라왔다 정도로 보시면
될 거 같고요. 세 번째는 디지털
크레디 securties
repurchase 프로그램 그러니까
연구 우선주를 재매입하는
프로그램입니다. 자사주 매입과 거의
비슷하다라고 보시면 될 거 같은데
자기들이 발음한 연구 우선주를 다시
사 드리겠다라고 하는 계획을 발표를
했습니다. 그래서 여기다가 한 1년
정도 규모의 우선주를 재매입할 계획이
있다라고 발표를 해줬고요. 해당
우선주들이 할인된 과치에 거래된다라고
매입하에서 배당 부담을 줄이겠다라고
했습니다. 그래서 준비금 지금 갖고
있는 현금에서 사는게 아니라이 1빌년
규모는 그 비트코인을 매도해 가지고
다시 잼매입하겠다라고 발표를
했습니다. 그래서 루나와 테라
데드스파를 제가 써 놨는데요. 아까
말씀드린 것처럼 스테이블 포인 매도가
발생을 하니까 그 반대편에 있는 것을
팔아서 어를 오게 됩니다. 그러다
보니까 그 담보 가치가 확 붕괴가
되게 되고 루나 그니까 그 새로 막
팔고 있던 루나 쪽에서도 가격이 막
폭락을 하게 되면서 이게 영 그 무한
분리로 돌게 되면서 그 둘 다 가격의
가치가 폭락을 했는데요. 제가이 그
데드스파를 가져온 이유는 액면가
그처에 고정을 하기 위해서 지금 그
STRC 가격을 좀 부양하겠다라는
것이 메인 정책인데 그러면 지금
MSTR이 아니라 그 비트코인 같은
걸 판매해 가지고 지금 이쪽으로 채워
주겠다라고 하는 것을 지금 메인
플랜으로 내줬는데요. 결국에
MSTR의 가치가 비트코인의 가치와
거의 레버리지 성격으로 붙어서 가기
때문에 비트코인을 팔게 된다라고 하면
MSTR의 가치가 같이 떨어지게
되는게 거의 기정 사실화가 되어
있습니다. 그럼 이게 반대편에 있는
그 안정돼 있는 어 연구 우선주를
사기 위해서 비트코인을 사는 것이
정말이 데드스 스파이럴의 구조가 어
오히려 유사해지는 거 아닌가 하는
생각을 이번 전에 개인적으로 하게
됐고요. [목을 가다듬음]
그래서 아기 전에 말씀드린 것처럼
스트레티지 배당 커버리지가 이번에
조금 현금을 많이 확보를 하게 되면서
조금 올라온 부분은 확인하실 수가
있게 되지만 어쨌든 구조상으로 변화이
전혀 없다라고 말씀드릴 수 있을 것
같고요. 루나 테라 사건에서 교훈을
얻은 투자들은 스트레티지 해당 정책이
어 STC의 액명가 회기에 기여하는
것이 아니라 연세적인 담보 가치
붕괴와 우선주 폭락으로 이어지는 것이
아닌가 하는 우려가 남았습니다.네
번째로는 MSTR 자사주 매입
프로그램입니다. 그래서 1일년 정도
규모 넣어서 그 보통주 MSTR
보통주도 재매입할 계획이 있다라고
설명을 해는데 이미 이번에 현금을
발행을 현금을 확보를 하기 위해서
20% 정도의 그 시가 총액이
날아갔거든요. 그니까 희석이
됐거든요. 그래서 그런 부분들로 어
이게 회 그 다시 회복이 되는가 하는
건 조금 의심이 된다라고 생각이 되면
될 거 같고
>> 이번 어 그 MS 자사주 매입할 때도
평는게 아니라 비트코인 매도한
자금으로 사겠다라고 계획을
발표해줬다라 보시면 될 것 같습니다.
다섯 번째로는 비트코인 현금한
프로그램입니다. 그래서 아래
목적으로만 비트코인 매도하겠다라고 어
설명을 해 줬는데 현금 부족할 때
그래서 한 1.2억 2억년 정도
규모에서 팔 수도 있다라고 설명해
줬고 어 ATM 그니까 주 주주를
희석하는 것보다 어 비트코인을
매도하서이자 및 배당을 지급하는게
유리할 때 그리고 세 번째로는 아까
말씀드린 것처럼 어 연구 우선주나
MSTR의 매입 자금이 필요할 때
다시 재매입하는 자금이 필요할 때
그렇게 하겠다라고 세 가지를 설명을
해 줬고요. 그래서 마지막에 그 해당
프로그램은 디지털 신용을 좀
강화시키면서 준비금 확대 배당 및이자
지급의 목적으로지 스트레티지의
유연성을 불어넣어 준다라고 회사측에
의견 설명이 있었는데 어 결론 쪽을
보시면 제가 볼 때는 조금 반대로
시장을 해석한다. 그리고 단기적으로는
그렇게 해석할 수 있지만 장기적으로
봤을 때는 엄청 큰 변화였다라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 그래서
결론적으로 보시면 스트레디지는 이번
결정으로 회사 보유 자산인 비트코인을
기반으로 여러 증권을 발행을 하고 그
증권에 있는 상품의 가격과 상품에서
나오는 배당을 관리하는 투자 회사로
사실 바뀌어 버렸습니다. 그래서
비트코인을 담보로 파생돼 있는
증권이나 연구 우선주 아니면 뭐 다른
상품들이 나올 수가 있을 것 같고요.
그 상품들에 나오는 걸 관리하는 투자
회사로 휘봇을 하게 돼 버렸다라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 그래서 기본
자금 조달 수단인 STRC의 할인율이
만약에 더 깊어지고 어 전환 사체
등의 자른 자부 자금 조달 수단이 좀
막혔기 때문에 이런 결정을 하게 될
수밖에 없었지 않나 하는 생각을
개인적으로 하게 됐고 사실 좀
늦었다라고 말씀을 드리는게 어
비트코인이 상승하는 그런 장세에서
우린 이럴 수 있다라는 것을 조금
언급을 해 줬으면 이런 부분들이
하락폭 이렇게 깊어지고 어 STRC
자금 조달 수단이 조금 막히진 않았을
것 같은데 어 너무 늦었다라는 생각을
좀 개인적으로 하고 있고요. 그래서
단기적으로는 그 연구선주인 STRC를
롱을 하고 그 MSTR을 숏을 하는
그런 페어가 오히려 좀 일시적인 어
투자 기회라고 보일 정도로 롱쇼지담
나오는 그 지금 투자 결정이 아닌가
하는 생각을 할 정도로 중대한
결정이었고요. 장기적으로 봤을 때는
2026년에 유일한 매수 수요였던 어
MSTR과 그 수요가 어 ETF와
더불어 좀 증발할 수 있는 어 그래서
비트코이 약세가 좀 지속될 수 있는
상황이 연출이 됐다라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 스트레티지가 최근 소송이
걸린 내용도 비트코인을 기반으로 한
연구선주인 어 STIC에 대한 과대
광고였기 때문에 더욱 과감하게
배당이나 또는 뭐 배당 지급을 조금
연기한다던가 배당 형태를 바꾼다던가
그런 선택지를 절대 가지 못했다라고
생각을 하고 있고요. 그리고 마지막
문장이 좀 결정적인데요. MSC에서
MSCI에서 태출 판단을 위해서
내려보고 있 노려보고 있는 포인트인이
회사가 투자 회사인가 아니면 그냥 어
소프트웨어 회사인데 그냥 전략적
자산으로 비트코인을 가지고 있는가 그
기준을 거의 포기한 거 같다라는
의견이 등장을 했습니다. 그게 왜
그러냐면 어 일반적인 회사가
회사에서 하는 거 같이 그냥
전략적으로 비트코인을 그냥 모으기만
하는게 아니라 지금 하는 거는
비트코인 담보로 한 상품들의 가격을
관리하거나 거기 나오는 배당들을 어
관리하거나 또는 그 배당을 나오는 그
상품들을 재매입하겠다라고 하는 지금
프로그램으로 가고 있기 때문에 어
MSI에서는 어이 회사가 투자
회사다라고 하면 어 그 DAT
기업으로 인정하지 않고
퇴출시키겠다라고 하는 기준을 발표를
했었습니다. 그래서 그런 기준들이
지금 MCI에서 계속해서 어 그
조사를 하고 있는 것 중에 조금 안
좋은 선택이지 않았나? 그러니까
MSC 퇴출 입장에서는 MSI 지수
편입에서 좀 안전 선택이 아니었나라는
생각 할 수 있었을고요. 오른쪽에는
스트레티지 현 직원의 블라인드 비슷한
글이 하나 있어서 어 그냥 간단하게
가져왔습니다. 이게 사실인지 아닌지
저 사실 파악을 하기 좀 어려워서
그냥 참고용으로만 봐 주시면 될 거
같고요. 그래서이 여기서 지금 직원이
말하는 거는 소프트웨어 비즈니스는
그냥 어 허상에 가깝다. 그냥 그냥
있는 거고 MSI 인덱스에서 편출되지
않기 위해서 사업을 진행하고 있고 어
그냥 비트코인을 모으는 것만 지금
주구 작하고 있다라는 어 현 직원에
어 그런 코멘트도 있었기 때문에 어
다양하게 좀 제가 많은 내용을
말씀드렸는데 결국에 말씀드리려고 하는
거는 결국에 지금 비트코인을 어 담보
자산으로 해서 여러 증권을 좀
발행하고 그 증권을 발행하는 아
증권을 좀 관리 그 증권이나 상품을
관리하는 회사로 완전 바뀌어 버렸다.
근데 그 선택이 좀 늦은 거 같다를
말씀드리려고 좀 장황하게
말씀드렸는데요. 어쨌든 어 MSI
지수도 지수에서도 좀 편출될 수 있는
확률이 굉장히 커졌다라고 말씀드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다.
>> 감사합니다. [목을 가다듬음] 시간이
좀 많이 지났지만 그래도 궁금한 거
한 가만 좀 여쭤보고 넘어가면
가상자산의 생태계에 대해서 정확히
이해하고 계신 분이라면 오늘 준역
설명을 듣고 이렇구나 이렇구나 이렇게
변화했구나라고인지를 딱 하셨을 텐데
저처럼 이렇게 코리니 수준인 사람은
이거 다시 한번 또 읽어보고 꼼꼼히
체크해 보고 해야 될 거 같아요.
그래서 어 관련해서 일단 단 어
요약을 좀 해 보자면
>> 네
>> 어 저희가 비트코인을 중심으로 한
가상자산 생태계에서 스트레티지가
생존해야 되니까 본인들의 비즈니스
모델을 좀 바꾸고자 하는 여러
노력들을 지금 시장과 소통하고 있는데
이것들 때문에 우리가 가상자산 시장에
만약에 투자를 하고 계신 분이라면 어
이런 어떤 어 스트레티지를 포함한
가상자산과 관련되 있는 회사에
투자하는 거는 지금 여러 가지므로
불안정한
어 셋업이 좀 있어서 그냥 비트코인
자체를 보유하고 있던가 아니면 시기를
좀 뒤로 미루는게 어떨까는 짐작을
하고 있거든요. 동의해 주시면
넘어가겠습니다.
>> 어 네네. 맞습니다. 그냥 이게 약간
어 우주 산업인데 스페이스 X가
굉장히 큰 트러블에 있다. 거의이
정도 급으로 봐 봐도 될 거
같습니다.
>> 알겠습니다. 저희 아침마다 공부를 좀
더 자세히 더 시켜 주세요. 그리고
약속의 9월 10월까지 쭉 공부하면서
가겠습니다. 1부 좀 많이
지났습니다.이 상황 마치도록 하고
2부에서 뵐 텐데요. 1부 함께 해
주신 최물 여러분 감사드리고
[목을 가다듬음] 잠시 2부에서
뵙도록 하겠습니다. 감사합니다.
>> [음악]
>> เฮ
[음악]
안녕하세요. 투자의 여정을 체슬리
투자 전문과 함께 체슬리 모닝 브리프
오늘 7월 1일
오늘이 수요일죠. 주요일
>> 하반기 2026년 하반기 첫날 2부
순서 시작하도록 하겠습니다.
>> 어젯밤 미국 시장은 기분 좋게 모두
상승 마감으로
>> 끝났고 해외 시장이 이렇게 저렇게 쭉
보다 보니까 영국 시장이 코로나 때
>> 예
>> 3월 27일 날 4,993을 기록을
했었는데
>> 예
>> 이제 많이더라고요. 아
>> 코로나 때 대비해서 딱 두 배
올랐는데
>> 우리가 1430
기록을 했었으니까
지금 코로나대 비하면
여섯 개 올랐어요.
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 어
>> 대단한 상승세입니다.네
>> 대단한 상승세를 보면 보이고
있습니다.
>> 예 어제
금리가 7bp 정도 상승을 했는데
국제 입찰이 좀 있었어요. 한 81년
달러 정도인데 응율이 이전에 비해서
좀 낮더라고요. 그래서 아 국채
매수가 조금 적었고요. 그리고
그 고용 지표 중에서 좀 보고 있는
졸트보고서가 나왔는데 부인 건서가
생각보다 좀 잘 나왔습니다. 그러다
보니까 약간 좀 금리의 상승 압력이
작용하지 않았나 싶고요.
일단은 그 이외에 4월 케이스 실러
어 20개 도시 주택 가격
나왔다는데음
계속 좀 슬로우한 편입니다.
실제로 어 전년 동기 대비 1.1%
상승했고요. 어 컨센서스 0.9%는
약간 상했습니다. 전원이
0.9%고요. 보라고요.
도시별로 보면은 좀 상한데
뉴욕이나 보스턴 이런 동부 쪽에 어
도시들이 어 뭐 3.8% 2.1%
올랐고요. 서부 쪽에선 샘플 시스가
한 1.3% 올랐고 이때 서부
쪽에서도 뭐 LA 같은 경우는
0.5% 5% 정도 하락해서 이것을
합산하니까 한 1.1% 정도 상승이
나왔고 중요한 거는
그이 주택 가격이 어 좀 낮게 어
상승률이 좀 낮게 유지되면서 어
주거비 물가가
또 같이 어 연동해서 안정적으로
유지가 된다고 되고 있다는 건데 현재
3.3% 3% 수준으로 주거의 물가가
어 유지가 되고 있기 때문에
CPI에서 많은 비중을 찾은이 주어
물가가 그냥 튀어서
CPI에 좀 충격을 줄 가능성은 좀
낮다고 생각을 합니다.
졸트보거서 나왔는데 91건수가
759만 4천000건이 나왔고 전월이
758만 5천000건 그래서 한 만
건 정도 어 좀 전널보다 높게 나왔고
어 컨센서스보다는 한 30만 건 정도
어 높게 나왔습니다.
9인
구직 대비 9인 비율을 보면은 어
1.04가 나왔거든요. 어 아무래도
이제 9인 건수가 좀 높다 보니까
그런데 4월이 1.03이었고요.
03이었고요. 3월이
0.95였습니다. 95였습니다.
그래서 최근에 고용 지표가 제조
PMI에서도 그렇고 서비스
PMI에서도 그렇고 좀 좋게 어
확인이 되고 있고 어 오늘 고용 지표
나오는데 실험률 4.3% 어 나오는데
벌써 그 4월 5월 해 가지고 오늘
4.3% 나오면은 3개월째 4.3%를
%를 유지하는 거가 되는데 어 고용
쪽에서 뭐
그렇게 막 다운사이드 리스크가 크게
부각되거나 뭐 이러지는 않을 것
같습니다.
대략적으로 어제 나온 매크로 지표
살펴봤고
어 6월 상반기가 지났는데 어
전반적으로
6월은 어땠고 어 상반기는 어땠고
그리고 거기에서 얻을 수 있는
시사점은 뭐고 포트폴리오 운용 쪽에서
좀 참고할 만한 건 뭔지 좀 생각을
해 봤습니다. 신기한게 하나
있습니다.이 숫자 중에서 정말로
신기했는데 일단 좀 보시죠. 6월에
일본이 5.6%가 올랐습니다.
미케지수 기준으로. 그리고 어 좀
전에 전부님 영국 지수도 말씀하셨는데
아 범 유럽 지수라고 하는 유로
스타스 60 2.5% 올랐고요.
그리고 상해 종합이 0.6% 코스피가
딱 보합으로 끝났습니다. 이게 소수점
한 선호자네 다섯짜리까지 하면 뭐
조금 올라 수준으로 0.3포인트
3포인트 뭐 이렇게 5월 말 기준으로
좀 오은 걸 확인했었고요. SMP
500은 1.1%가 하락을 했고요.
어 주국 지수 상승률은 어 코스피가
101.1%로 어 100%를
넘었습니다. 그리고 니케가
39.2%고요.
SP 500이 두 자릿수를 아직 못
기록하고 있습니다. 9.6%
올랐고요. 그리고 법유럽 지수인
유럽이 8.4% 4% 상해 종합이
3.3% SMP 500이 연간으로
보면 한 어 10% 내외 정도 어
연평균 상승률을 기록하는데 상반기
9.6% 6% 했다는 건 그렇게 뭐
나쁜 성적은 아닙니다.
아 주요 지수 보면은
아 6월에 어 필반 지수 어 11%가
올랐고요. 러셀리 2천이 3.6%
6% 올라서 대체로 미국 쪽에서 어
반도체하고 어 중소용주 쪽이
전반적으로
다른 섹터 대비 좀 강했고 다우가 좀
구경제 주식들로 유지가 그 구성이 돼
있는데 어 금리가 약간 좀 내려오다
보니까 어 헬스케어라든지 금융 이쪽이
좀 오르면서 다우지수도 상대적으로 어
단단했고요.
SMP 500 말씀드렸던 대로
1.1% 1% 하락했고 나스닥은
2.8% 하락했는데 이따 보시겠지만
빅탱크 쪽의 하락이 나스닥 하락을
이끌었다라고 보시면 될 거 같고요.
YTD로 보면은 필반 지수
101.1%입니다.
그리고 러셀 21.9% 나스닥
12.8%
SM 9.6% 바우지수
8.9%입니다.
여기까지 뭐 신기한 거 발금 못
했습니까?
>> 여기까지요?
>> 예. 예. 어
>> 막 하나 있습니다.
나는 이거 보면서 오늘예
>> 내일 촬영할 월간 전망
>> 예
>> 자료 만들어야 되는데 아 최부사요
자료로 월관 전망 자료
>> 저거 해야 되겠다 싶었는데
>> 일단 우리나라 코스피 딱 0%로 끝난
거 요것도 조금 재밌었고
>> 그렇죠
>> 그다음에음
잠깐만
>> 모르겠다
>> 예 그렇어요 연초 이후에 코스피 상승
상승률 101.1%잖아요.
>> 코스피 상승률이
>> 예 101.1%인데
>> 어 필반도 101.1이네.
>> 예 그렇습니다.
>> 아 [웃음]
>> 야
>> 그래서
>> 아 그렇네요.
>> 결국 필반하고 코스페하고 어 같이
간다.
>> 음.
>> 근데 숫자까지 막 이렇게 맞춰서
>> 상반기에 끝날 줄은 몰랐습니다.
>> 그렇네요. 진짜요? 야 101.1.
>> 예. 그다음에
>> 아니 쭉 그냥 코스피랑 필반이랑 그냥
앞으로도 10년 20년 100년 필반
지수랑이 똑같이 갔으면 좋겠
>> 그러니까요.
어쨌든 올해 그 반도체 위주로 어
미국 주식 투자하셨던 분들
성과에
대해서음
괜찮았을 거라고 생각을 하고 있고요.
어, 미국 주요 종목 쪽 보시면은
주요 상승 종목 보면은 6월만 딱
떼놓고 봤을 때 AI 인프라 쪽인데
조금 음, 재밌었던 거는 반도체는 뭐
당연히 있는 건 맞는데 건설하고 전력
기기
캐터필라하고 G번호바 이쪽이 좀
강했더라고. 캐터필라가
다섯 번째 쪽 보시면 22%
올랐고요. G번호가가 21%
올랐습니다. AI 인프라 쪽에서 결이
같은데 유틸리티도 있고 뭐 전택 뭐가
있는데 어 이쪽 그 산업지 쪽에서
캐터필러하고 뒤번호바가
오르면서 산업제 섹터가 올해 상승률로
봤을 때 11개 섹터 중에서 제일
높은 상승률을 기록을 하고 있습니다.
그 이후에 건강 관리가
존슨 존슨, 일라이 머이
좀 올랐거든요. 그래서 어 존슨 존슨
13%
아 그 머도 한 8% 정도
올랐습니다. 금융 쪽에서 어 JP모건
웰스바고 버크스 이런 쪽도
두 자릿수 쭉 올랐고요. 어 JP목은
뭐 정도 올랐고 어 뱅커 미니카도
10% 그래서 대형주 위주로 금융
쪽에서 좀 괜찮았다라고 보시면 될 거
같고 기타 쪽에서 레이시온 테크놀로지
방산 업체가 한 6% 올랐고요.
코카콜라가 한 3% 정도 올랐습니다.
주요 하락 종목은 대체로 빅테크가
이끌었는데요. M7이라고 읽컫는 뭐
테슬라, Nv디아, 구글, 그리고
애플, 메타, 아마존, 그리고 M7은
아니지만 브로드컴, 마이크로소프트,
특히 마이로소프트가 한 17% 정도
하락을 했습니다. 그리고 어, 유가가
빠지다 보니까 엑슨 모빌 같은 주식이
모멘텀이 약화가 됐고요. 오라클이
35% 올랐고 팔란티어도 한 25%
정도 올랐습니다. 대체로 어 보면은
그 하락을 주도했던 종목들은 계속해서
그 돈을 써야 되는 쪽에서 어
모멘텀이
어 약화가 어 이루어지고 있고요. 그
반대쪽에
그 수혜를 받는 쪽에서는 모멘텀이
계속 어 지속이 되고 있는 거를 알
수 있고 중간중간에 이제 매크로
환경에 따라서 금융이나 그리고 어
건강 관리 이런 쪽에 개별 종목들
특히 어 시총 상위 종목들 쪽에서 어
강세를 나타내는 그런 현상이
나타났습니다. 제가 볼 때는 그냥
매크로이라는 이제 그 투자 전략이
있는데 매크로에 따라서 어 투자를 그
섹터나 뭐 이렇게 투자하다 보니까
대형주 위주로 좀 오르지 않았나 이런
생각이 들고요. 6월 필반 지수 아까
6월에만 11.1% 올랐고 뭐 그
연초 대비로 해서 100 101.1%
1% 올랐다고 했는데 여기에서도
약간의 뭐 미세한 변화가 좀 감지가
됐는데 아무래도 여기저기서 그 투자
관련된 소식이 나옵니까
뭐 파운드리나 CPU, 메모리,
장비, 네트워킹이 대체로 상승하는
가운데 어 특히 상승률이 좋았던 거를
보면은
램 리서치 같은 경우가 36.2%가
%가 올랐고요. 어플라이드 머티리얼이
60.6%가 올랐습니다. 그리고
KL이 검사 장비인데 57%가
올랐습니다. 그리고 어 광 네트워킹
쪽에서 마블이나
아 아리스탈랩 요쪽도 40%
이상으로는 그런 모습이 관찰됐습니다.
그 외 어 파운드리 쪽에서 TSMC도
14% 정도 올랐고 메모리 18.9%
9% 아 아이콘 테크놀로지 기준으로
올랐고요. 기타 그 저장 장치 쪽에서
샌디스크 34% 웨슨 리스털 20%
그리고 어 ETF 중에서 이제 D램이
16.9% 올랐고요. SXX가
12.6% 6% 그래서 충실히 그
SXX는 필반 지수를 추종하고 있는
걸로 보여지고요.
신고가 종목 중에서 좀 전에
말씀드렸던
파운드리나 CPU나 장비나 그리고
네트워킹 쪽에서 친구가 나오고 있고
아직까지 그 메모리 쪽에서는 마이크론
테크놀로지 기준으로 봤으는 한 5%
정도 좀 욕한 편입니다.
밸루에이션을 점검을 해 보면은 PR
기준으로 지금 일반 지수가
26.5배에 5배 거래되고 있는데요.
최근 고점이 어 29배 정도였습니다.
1년 기준으로 해 보면요.
그래서 이전에 약간 이제 주가가
오르면서
일반 지수가 그 PR 기준으로 고점
부분에서 좀 조정을 받는 모습들이
관찰이 됐었는데 지금은 26.5배라음
5배라. 음.
주가가 거의 거의 이제 신고가
부근임에도 불구하고 PR은 좀 낮아
있는 그런 상황인데 결정적으로 어
필반주수의 PR를 낮추는데 마이크론
테크놀러지의
기어도가 커스 커스 추정하는데 위에
보면은 어 마이콘 테크놀로지가 지금
필반 지수 실총 상위 종목에 있는데
4위까지 올라왔습니다.
1위는 아시다 Nv디아고요. 2위는
어 TSM, 3위는 워로드컴, 4위가
이제 마이크론 테크날로지인데 어
지난주 실적 발표를 하면서 마이콘
테크날로지의 EPS가 한 주 동안에
32%나 어 올랐거든요. 그렇기
때문에이
마이콘 테크놀로지가 상위 종목에서 어
전체 필반 지수의 EPS를
끌어올리는데 기어를 했고 그에 따라서
PER도 주가가 올랐음에도 불구하고
좀 낮아졌을 가능성이 있다라고 추정을
해 볼 수 있고요. 지금 PR은 8점
마이콘 테크놀로지 PR은 8.4대까지
4대까지 어 내려온 상황입니다.
그래서 전반적으로 좀 시사점을 보면은
AI 인프라 내에서 반도체하고 어
관련 산업제 종목은 강한 모멘텀을
유지하고 있고요. 다만 반도체 섹터
내에서도 상승 모멘텀의 강도가
순환적으로 좀 다르게 나타나는데 아
그때그때 뉴스플로어에 따라서 어떤
때는 메모리, 어떤 때는 장비, 어떤
때는 파운드리, 어떤 때는 CPU,
어떤 때는 또 네트워킹인데 최근에
신고가 돌파한 종목권을 보면은
장비하고 파운더리하고 CPU 네트워킹
쪽입니다.
그 이외 금리하고 매크로 견수에
따라서 일부 건강 관리하고 금융 등의
반등이 관찰이 됐고요. 어 M7을
비롯한 빅테크들의 케펙스 투자 아
부담 우려 등으로이 그 종목들은
상대적으로 소외가 됐는데 어제 그
아침에 어 살펴본 바와 같이 어
케펙스는 계속해서 어 가속화되고
있음을 시장에서인지를 하고 있고요.
어 컨센서스상으로 보면은
하이퍼스케일러 4계사 기준으로 봤을
때 아마존이 50% 정도의 YY
케펙스가 증가하고 것으로 예상하고
있고 어이를 제외한 마이크로소프트,
메타, 구글은 어 전년 동기 대비
100% 내외 케펙스가 증가할 걸로
보고 있습니다. 근데 이번 다음
분기도 뭐 110%, 120% 뭐
이렇게 되면서 어 일부 메타 같은
경우
프리캐시 플로우가 마이너스로 어
들어가게 될 걸로 어 보여지고
있고요.
어, 클라우드 사업자들의 2분기
클라우드 매출을 봐야 되는 거는 전방
수요가 그만큼 세야지만 피팩스를 더
어, 확충할 가능성도 커지는데 아마존
같은 경우는 클라우드 매출 A,
AWS 같은 경우 볼 때 아, 이번에
31.1% 어, 매출이 증가할 걸로
보여지고 있고 어, 마이크로소프트는
24.6% % 구글은 64% 정도로
어 클라우드 쪽에서는 구글이 상당히
치고 나가는 걸로 보여주고 있습니다.
그래서 어 이번에 비트크 쪽에서 그
체크해 달 코멘트는 어 앞단의 수요가
여전히 세고 수요 대비 공급이
부족하다. 그래서 어 케펙스를
가수화할 수밖에 없다라는 코멘트가
나오면 어 가장 좋을 것 같고요. 어
거기다가 가이던스도 시장 컨센서스
대비 세게 주게 되면 여전히 AI
인프라 쪽에서
모멘텀은 지속되고 것이고 클라우드
사업자들 쪽에서 또 그렇게 막 실적이
크게 깨질 정도로 나오지 않으면서 어
주가도이 지금 수준에서 유지될 걸로
보여지고 있습니다. 그래서 어
클라우드 수요가 견조하고 케펙스
경쟁이 지속되는 추세가 유지될 때
AI 인프라 사이클에 지속 가능성이
있어 보이고요. 한편 그 빅테크 특히
M7 이렇게 케픽스를 경쟁해야 되는
기업들은 주가 낙폭에 따라서 좀 제가
볼 때는 어 그때그때 뭐 그 AI
인프라 쪽이 너무 과열됐다라는 이런
어떤 우려등이 나오게 됐을 때 단기
반등은 가능하지만 추세적으로 주가
모멘텀 회복시까지는
좀 시간이 필요하지 않을까라고 생각을
하고 있고요. 그 외로 이제 금리
방향성하고 경기 지표증 등에 따라서
매크로 기반 트레이딩이 가능할 수
있는 영역이 있을 것 같은데 아까
보셨듯이 금융이나 건강 관리 섹터
이런 부분들은 금리에 좀 민감한
부분들이기 때문에 어 트레이딩을
고려할 수는 있겠죠.이 이 역시
섹턴에 종목 차별화 가능성이 있어
보여서 포트폴리오 관점에서 접근할
필요가 있다고 생각합니다.
이상입니다.
>> 네. 감사합니다. [웃음]
근데 저 같은 경우에는이 월관
전망자를 만들 때이
데이터들
>> 예,
>> 데이터 정리하는게 그렇게 귀찮더라고.
>> 아, 그래. 근데 우리 최부사랑은
매주 월요일 날 밸류에이션 저거
발표하고
그다음에 또 6월 말 끝난지지 지금
얼마 되지도 않았는데
이렇게 자료를 갔다가 참 보면
일을 보기보다 빨리빨리 잘하는 거
같아요.
>> 아 그런데 이게
>> 어 좀 그때그때 좀 다른데 막
데이터를 빨리 보고 싶을 수
있잖아요. 어, 그때는 좀 일의
속도가 굉장히 그 빠르게 나오는 거
같고요. 어떤 때는 어, 좀
그거보다는 흥미가 좀 덜할 때도
있는데 그럴 때는 좀 속도가 들린 거
같습니다.
>> 그래서 어, 이번 6월은 어차피 그기
그리고 반기 월 이게 이제 겹치는
구간이기 때문에 어, 데이터를 좀
빨리 정리하고 싶어서 어, 좀 벼르고
있었습니다. [웃음]
진짜 벼르고 있을
자, 그리고 좀 전에 이역 부장님이
또 적어 놓으셨었는데
그 미국 시장이
1950년 이후로예
>> 75년 동안 6월에 연간 SP
505점이 나온 한 번도 없었대요.
아,
>> 그래서 생각해 보니까 미국은 그러니까
연말이나 연말 연초에 나온 적은
많은데 예,
>> 우리나라 시장은 21년도만 하더라도
6월 25일 날
>> 그끝에 3,316 지급에서 고점
나왔었으니까
>> 예.
>> 우리는 있는데 거 보니까 미국은
없었던 거 같아. 음.
>> 그리고 뭐 강좌가 컨트월 전략 뭐
요런 것도 나오는데 7월은 또
전통적으로 또 시장이 약간 강한
시장.
>> 예.
>> 근데 7월부터 어닝 시즌이
시작되잖아요.
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 그래서 이번에 3월 달에는 이런
전쟁이 있었지만 또 6월 달, 3월
달 다 보면 그 어닝 시전이 끝나고
나서 그죠. 예.
>> 실적공백기에
>> 딱 조정이 좀 있었는데
>> 7월 8월은 보면 또 실적 발표시
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 지금 뭐 쫄트보고서나 이런 것도
나오고 ISM 제조 PMI 이런
것들은 좋게 나오잖아요.
>> 예.
>> 그래서 또 7월 달은 실적이 나쁘지
않을 거고 어 어떤 섹터나 어떤
종목들이 7월에도 올라갈까? 아,
근데 강세장이면
>> 가장 베타가 높은 거 유리프로한테
지난주 벌주에서 얘기했었잖아요. 그
베타 개념으로 따지면 또 일반이 베타
높기 때문에
>> 그렇습니다. 근데 이번 달에는 SP
500 마이너스했는데 또 플러스
11%나 예
>> 상승은 했었지만
>> 보면 7월이 또 강세장이면 어 미국
시장 나스닥이라든지
>> 나스닥의 그 지금 M7 종목들이나
요쪽들이 많이 좀 쩔어 있었는데
>> 예
>> 얘네들이 이번에는 반등이 들어가려나
아니면 계속이
창시 메모리 상장 뭐 이런 것도
>> 나와 있고 7월 7월 달에 말에는
삼성전자 하이닉스 실적 발표하고
이번에도 뭐 천씩 뭐 투자하겠다 뭐
이런 거 계속 나오니까네
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 장비주들의 랠리가
좀 더 이어질 것 같기도 하고 뭐
>> 예 그게 지금 그 말씀하신게 어
운영자 관점에서 핵심이라고 생각을
하는데 아 제가 가장 그 집중하고
신경 써서 보는 부분입니다. 그래서
지금이 그 AI 인파 반도체 뭐
산업제 이쪽의 랠리가 계속 되려면 어
좀 더 많은 이제 모멘텀이 강하게 어
나와야 되는데 그쪽에서 좀 약화가 될
경우에는 섹터 확산이 이루어지면서
>> 어 지금까지 강했던 부분들이 소외가
될 수 있기 때문에
>> 그때는
좀 진짜 뭔가 좀 어 바뀐다. 색깔이
바뀐다고 했을 때는 아 기민하게 그
대응할 생각이고요. 일부 그 IB들
쪽에서는 그 그런 주장을 하는 그
아이비들도 있는데 특히 이제 JP보건
같은 경우는 아 우리나라의 그 삼성자
하이닉스 어 대기모 투자를 두고 어
그 투자가 단기적으로는 뭐 그 반도체
세트를 어 긍정적으로 보지만 어
장기적으로는
약간 그 지금 모멘텀 자체가 아 좀
다운될 수 있다. 아, 그런 얘기를
하면서 미국 시장에서도 자칫 섹터
확산이 일어날 수 있다라고 주장을
하고 있거든요. 근데 그 주장이 맞기
위해서는 어, 결국 이제 케펙스를
주도적으로 투자하는 빅테크들의
스탠스가 관건이 될 것 같습니다.
그래서 제가 보기에는 그 의견을
전적으로 받아들이거나
받아들이지 않거나 어쨌든 염두에 두고
있다가 이번에 어 정말 그 비테크들의
스스가 어떤지에 대해서 진지하게
고민을 한 다음에 어 대응을 해야
되지 않을까라고 싶습니다라고 생각을
하고 있습니다.
[목을 가다듬음]
자, 그리고 어, 제가 꾸역꾸역
올라온다는 말 자주 썼는데 그 악재가
없는게 아니거든. 악재가 없는게
아님에도 불구하고
>> 예. 계속 이렇게 머리 쳐들면서 계속
징격 부러워합니다.
>> 예. 그럴 때 이제 제가 어 참
꾸역꾸역 그래도 올라온다 이런 표현을
썼는데
이번 7월에도
범피범피하면서
올라갈 거다라고 생각하는게 어제 고용
이런 것들이 잘 나오다 보니까
>> 음
>> 이번에 CPI도 한 7월 10날
언절이 나올 거잖아요. 예. 어,
CPI도 5월 지금 7월에 발표하는게
이제 6월 CPI이기 때문에
>> 그렇습니다.
>> CPI도 아마 좋게 나올 것. 이런
부분들이 어제 그 결국 어젯밤에
10년물 국제 금리가 또 위로 튀면서
4,45 갔잖아요.요
>> 부분은 또 아 이제 돌격 앞으로
하려고 하는데 또 금리가에 상단을 또
막는
>> 약간 심리적인 부담을 주는 그런
모습으로 작용할 거고요. 그러다
보니까 비트코인 같은 경우에 어제 또
빠졌어요.
>> 예예. 58,700불까지
이렇게 빠지는 모습이 나오기 때문에
어 중간중간에 어 내가 언제 좀
주식을 좀 담을까 요럴 때 그런 아까
매크로 배치라고 말씀도 해 주셨는데
>> 예이 금리를 자극할 수 있는이 물가
데이터가 또 7월 달에 나올 거고
그리고 또 그걸 바탕으로 해서 FMC
회의가 7월 29일 날 있기 때문에
예. 그런 것들이 어 시장에 있어서는
또 찬물을 한 번씩 끼었는 그런
작용을 할 거기 때문에 어 너무 지금
아직까지는 7월까지는 추세 추종령 정
전략 올라가는 거 보고 쫓아사기보다는
>> 예 중간중간에
>> 그런 스코이 올 때마다
활성 투자로 하는 전략이
>> 7월에도 계속 유효하다. 요렇게 월간
전망 적으려고. 아예
>> 그 그렇지 않아도 전문 2월 달에 한
그 코스피 전망을 보니까 아래 위로
8% 이렇게 적어 놓으셨더라고요.
약간 십자가 모양으로 예상을 해서
정확하게 그 맞추신 거 같은데 물론
이제 어 밑으로는 12% 위에는
10% 뭐 이렇게 됐는데 아 정말
그거 보면서 대단하다는 생각했습니다.
>> 아유 감사합니다. 아유 우리 최부
사장님 칭찬 잘 안 하는데 그렇지
유리야
칭찬 잘 안 하지 않잘하면
잘해주신 [웃음]
>> 최구사장한테 그 칭찬들릴 때가 참
기분 제일 좋습니다. 왜냐면
>> 기준이 제일 까다로운 분 있잖아
그렇잖아요.
>> 어 우리 회사에서이 가장 우석기가 살
웃는데네
>> 인정하세 인정하십니까?
>> 네
>> 선구 매니저 인정하십니까?네 네.
[웃음]
>> 가장 까다로운 기준으로 우리 채슬리
투자분을
선봉해서 이끌고 계시기 때문에
그래서 우리 최부사장 밑에서 좀
배우고 싶다 이런 분들이 많아졌어요.
>> 아, 그렇습니까?
>> 예. 채밀터 근데 배워본 사람
입장에서는 한마디 한번 해 보세요.
>> 영어 중에 엑스포넨셜이라는 표현
있잖아요. 가속장.
>> 엑스포넨셜.
>> 네. 완전 기아 급수적 성장.
>> 이뤄낼 수 있습니다.
>> 어 배우면 이렇게 된다.
>> 네.
>> 유리프로가 확실히 사회생활 잘했어.
>> 어 난 그럴 줄 알았거든.
>> 각오하고 오셔야 됩니다. 그런 거.
성구 성구가 그런 말 했던 거 같은데
>> 그렇지 않나?이
이 쉽지 않아질 수 [웃음]
>> 예 삶이 쉽지 않아질 수가 있다고
최부사장 밑에서 좀 일 배우고 싶다
하시는 분들 삶이 일시적으로 굉장히
피폐해질 수 있습니다. [웃음]
그걸 각오하고 오셔야 됩니다.
자 참 그리고 어제 제가 신차
구분인석을 까먹고 못 올렸는데
죄송합니다. 어제
>> 아들이 기국을 해 가지고요. 아,
>> 알람을 오후에 맞춰 놨었는데 신차
분석 알람을 신차 분석 찍어야지
해놓고 상담하고
그리고 이제 5시 반 6시에
아들이 이제 인천공항에음
>> 와 오고 아버지가 또
>> 리무진 타고 가서
>> 음 [목을 가다듬음]
>> 올 때는 지하철 같이 오는 사진 보고
하면서
>> 거기 아들 만날 생각
>> 정신에 없어 가지고
>> 얼마나 애트 어떻하겠습니까? 진짜
>> 예. 아들 귀국한 아들 바로
>> 어 부모님 택에서 딱 만나자마자
축구잡으로 제가 되고 [웃음]
어제 저녁
송파 여성 축구장에서 8시에
실컷하는데 하다가 9시에 문자를
봤더니 전모님 신차 분석 언제
올리시에
왔어요.
>> 예예. 아 그거 보고
나는 왜 이렇게 치민하지 못할까?
우리 최부사처럼 좀 세하게 뭔가 일을
다 해야 되는데
현사 분석 못 올려서 이번 주는 원래
화술목 올리는데 이번 주는 금요일까지
제가 올리려고요. [웃음]
>> 자
미국 시장까지 쭉 봤고요. 그다음에
국내 시장으로 넘어가 보도록
하겠습니다.
>> 네. 전일 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
스피지 수 1%대 상승으로
마감했고요. 코스닥은 0.5% 5%
하락으로 마감을 했습니다. 수급적으로
보면 개인 투사자가 8,억 가량
매수세가 있었고 외국인의 매도는
여전히 좀 강한데요. 3 8천억
매도가 있었습니다. 기관에서 매수가
또 좀 유입이 됐었는데 3조 가까이
매수가 유입됐던 모습이고요.
선물에서는 외인의 한 8,000
가량의 매도가 있었습니다. 투자자별
매매 동향으로 보면 어제 외국인
투자자는 삼성 전기를 약 4,억 정도
매수를 하는 모습이었고요. 그 외에는
대체로 IT나 소부자 종목들에 대한
매수세가 강했습니다. 이오테크, 원익
IPS, ISC, 리노버, 멜주
이노택 등을 매수를 했고요. 매도에는
SK하이닉스 1조 5,억 가량 그리고
삼성전자를 8,700억 가량 매도
했습니다.
월요일, 화요일 이렇게 봤을 때 전자
닉스 거의 하루에 각각 3조씩
봤었거든요. 어제는 좀 매도 규모
자체는 좀 축소됐던 모습이었고요. 그
외에는 SDI로 현대 중공 LG엔솔을
매도했었고
기관 매수에는 삼성전자 SK하닉스
스퀘어 삼성전기 이수페타시스 등을
매수를 했고요. 매도에는 이오테크
그리고 원니 IPS HPSP 리노
등을 매도했습니다. 기관에서는 소부장
종목들을 좀 매도한 반면에 외국인이이
물량을 좀 받아갔던 모습이었던 거
같고요. 52주 신고가는 14
종목이었는데
코스피에서 K시텍, 금호 건설, 미래
산업이 신고하였고요. 코스닥은
PSK, 심텍, 테스, VM,
기가스, 인바디 등이 어,
신고가였습니다.
코스닥에서는 역시나 소부 종목들이 어
한 여섯 종목 정도 나왔던 거
같습니다.
52주 신고가 종목도 조금씩 이제
다시 늘어나네요.
>> 네.
>> 외국인 매도 얘기해 주셨는데 외국인이
상반기에 아까 148조라고
거 150조를 팔았대.
6개월 만에 150조 파는 거는 역대
처음
>> 예. 네. 처음인 거 같은데 예전에
2005 6 7 2008년 금융미기
오기 전에 2005년 동안 70조
팔았거든요. 70조 팔았었는데
>> 이번에는 뭐 상반기에만 150조를
팔았는데
>> 시장은
101%
올라갔으니까
>> 그렇습니다. 그리고 매도가 또
삼성전자 하이닉스에 좀 집중이 된
부분도 있는데 오히려 코스피 200은
126%
>> 음
>> 그 딱 오가장이 한 달 전에
>> 네
>> 그 BMP 파라바 얘기하면서음
>> 파라바 사 줄게네
>> 그게 용기를 좀 준 거 같아 그래 뭐
오과장처럼 주식하자이
동화미분들이
그래 팔아봐 사 줄게
>> 근데 이제 7월 달부터는 국민연금 또
리밸런스 물락 나온다고.
>> 네.
>> 그래서 너무 걱정을 안 하셔도
되는게이 150조 외국인 물량을에도
불구하고 그죠. 오른실은 다 올라가.
>> 그렇습니다. 그죠. 근데 이제 나빠서
팔기보다는 너무 많이 올라서 일종에
트리밍이라고 할 수 있을 것
같은데요.
>> 그러니까 근본적으로 펀더멘탈이
나빠지면은 이제 그걸 걱정해야 되는
것이지 기계적으로 비중이 좀 높아서
그걸 좀 줄이는 거는 좀 뭐 일시적인
수급이나 심리 충격은 있을지라도
금방 복원력이 되게 강한 거 같죠.
자, 주요 종목들 동향 일단 한번 쭉
보겠습니다.
네. 반도체 소구장 섹터 먼저 보면
어제 대용 반도체에서 삼성전자의 주가
흐름이 좋았었고요. 3.4% 상승
마감했습니다. 반면에 하이닉스는
0.8% 8% 정도 오르면서 조금
차별한 흐름이 나타났었고요. 아래
소부장 종목들은
어 혼자세였는데 뭐 많이 올랐던
종목은 많이 오르고 또 빠졌던 종목
빠졌습니다. 이오테크 4% 올랐고
주성이 모처럼 반등이 좀 강했고요.
14% 급등 나왔습니다. 심텍도 강한
상승세에 보였는데 한 20% 정도
급등을 했고요. 그리고 대덕 전자도
한 16% 오르면서 기판 쪽의 흐름이
좀 상당히 좋았었던 거 같습니다.
아래 IT 섹터는 삼성 전기가 한
7% 오르면서 어제 좀 반등이
강했고요. 수주 공시도 있었습니다.
4,억대 MLCC 계약 공시가
있었고요. 그 외 LG 이노텍 7%
오르면서 여기도 기판 쪽이 상당히
좋았고 플랫폼 섹터는
그저께 좀 몰랐다가 어제 다시 좀
하락하는 모습이 나타났고 니케이 지수
0.8% 8% 상승 마감했습니다.
반도체 쪽에 반등이 좀 있었는데요.
도쿄 일렉트론 3% 무라타가 6%,
디스코 2% 오르면서 일본 증시에서도
MLCC 기업이 상당히 좋았던
모습이었고요.
자동차 섹터 봐주시면 현대차 기아
부진한 하루였고 소비자 섹터 그저께
좀 반등이 강하게 나왔었는데요.
하마리 서치를 제외하곤 다시 좀
약해지는 모습이 나왔습니다. 대용
화장품이나 OEM 피온용 계기쪽
대체로 부진한 흐름이었고요. 파마
홀로 한 4%대 상승으로
마감했습니다.
어, 그리고 아래 보시면 음식률 섹터
여전히 좀 부진한 흐름이 이어지고
있습니다. 삼양이 3.5 하락했고요.
백화점 체인 그저께 좀 안
좋았는데요. 어제 그래도 신세계가
어, 좀 반등에 성공하는 모습이었고
조선 철감 및 기타 섹터 봐 주시면
조선주들 어제는 좀 진했습니다. 하나
5,25% 정도 약세로 마감을
했고요.
오늘 철강화학 월요일장에 좀 반등
강했었는데 다시 좀 약세로 전환하는
모습이었고
방산주에서는 하나 여로 X1 로템
대체로 다 약세였습니다.
그리고 바이오섹터도
뭐를 반등세를 좀 강하게 보이다가
바로 약세 전환하는 모습이
나타났고요.
증권이나 은행 쪽 봐 주시면 어제
금융에서 KB 금융이 좋았고 키움
증권도 상승세 보였습니다. 엔터 쪽은
부진하게 마감을 하는 모습이었고요.
변화기 쪽 상당히 좋았는데 현대 1
뭐 효성중검 LS 일렉트릭 상승세를
보였습니다. 확실히 변합기는 약간
30회를 깨고 내려가면 좀 매수가 좀
강하게 들어오는 거 같습니다.
>> 음.
>> [목을 가다듬음]
>> 30회 깰 때마다 좀 얘기 좀 해
줘요.
>> 아유, 알겠습니다.
국내 주요 정시 동량 쭉 받고요.
자, 그다음에 어, 이연택 연구원
자료 한번 보겠습니다. 이거 그전
탑다운 밤다체 주가 조정의 원인과
7월 초 이후
반도체 얘기예요.
>> 네. 반도체 쪽 이야기고 좀 수급적인
이야기를 좀 해 주셨는데요. 반도체
업종 6월 업종 수익에서 여전히 상승
2위를 기록 중에 있다고 합니다.
아마 6월 하순부터는 주가가 크게
흔들리고 있는데 최근 메모리 반도체
주가락은 단일 요인으로 설명하기가 좀
어렵다라고 볼 수가 있고요. 따라서
이번 글에서는 시장에서 하락 원인으로
벌론되는 여러 요인들 가운데 의미
있는 것들만 좀 추여서 보고 현재
메모리 반도체 주가가 어디쯤 와
있는지 점검해 보려고 한다라고
합니다. 첫 번째 수급적 요인인데요.
반기 리밸런싱이나 스펙 X 나스닥팩
편입 이슈가 있다고 합니다. 뭐
반도체 약세의 [목을 가다듬음]
수급적 원인으로 거론되는 가운데 겉할
만한 것은 두 가지 정도인데 어
방길리 밸브런싱을 좀 먼저 말해 보면
어 방기말 또는 분기말의 연기금이나
펀드 ETF 등이 자산 비중을 다시
목표 비중으로다 맞추는 작업을
의미한다라고 하고요. 쉽게 말하자면
주식이 크게 올랐다면 주식 비중을
줄이고 채권 등 다른 자산의 비중을
늘리게 된다라고 하고 주식 안에서도
특정 업종이 너무 많이 올랐다면 해당
업종 비중을 줄이게 된다라고 합니다.
또한 아시아 주식 비중이 당초
목표보다 커졌다면 일부를 줄여 원래의
자산 배분 비중으로 되돌리는 현상이
나타나고 즉 반기 리밸런싱은 시장
전망이 나빠져서 파는게 아니라 많이
옳은 자살을 줄여서 정해준 정해둔
비중으로 되돌리는 기계적 매도라고 볼
수가 있겠다라고 합니다. 그다음은
스페이스 X의 나스닥 100백
편입인데요. 7월 7일 스페이스 X가
나스닥 100에 편입될 예정이라고
합니다. 어 스페이스 X는 시가 총액
기준으로 보면 미국 증신의 탑 6급에
해당하는 초대용 기업이라고 볼 수가
있고요. 따라서 스페이스엑스 편익
과정에서 기존 나스닥 구성 종목
일부를 매도해야 할 가능성이 분명히
있다라고 합니다. 다만 스페이스 X가
나스닥 100에 편입된다고 해서 약
2조 달러에 달하는 시가 총액이
그대로 지수에 반영되는 것은 아니라고
하고요. 실제 페리비 중 유동 주식
비율과 유동 주식 가중치 등에 따라
크게 달라진다라고 하고 어
모닉스타에서는 스펙스 X의 실제
나스닥 100의 비중을 약 1.8에서
한 1.2.6 정도 수준으로 보고
있고요. 따라서 편입 이후엔
반도체주에 단기 수급 부담이 있을 수
있겠지만 상대적으로 영향은 제한적일
수 있다라는 이야기를 했습니다.
그밖에 요인인데요. AI 투자 우려가
좀 있고 증설, 소송, 단기 과열
여러 가지 요인들을 좀 얘기했는데
어 먼저 AI 투자 우려는 다음
글에서 따로 분석할 예정이라고 하고
다만 AI 투자가 꺾이는게
지금인가라고 묻는다면 아직은 좀
아니다라는 의견이고요. 소송 이슈는
미국 캘리포니아 법원에 제기된 디램
가격 담합 집단 소송이 최근에
이슈화되고 있는데 현재 공개된
내용만으로는 메모리 반도체를 흔들
정도의 문제라고 보긴 어렵다. 그리고
반독점 소송에서 중요한 것은 가격이
급등했다는 사실이 아니라 담합이
있었다는 구체적 증거가 핵심이라고
하고요. 단기가열 부담은 조정 핵심
요인 중 하나라고 생각을 하는데 이번
상승 과정에서는 주가가 30일 이동
평균선을 하해 할 때마다 바닥으로
인식되는 경우가 있었다라고 합니다.
그래서 지금은 아직 남은 이격 부담을
해소하는 과정으로 볼 수가 있겠다라고
하고요. 최근 하락은 펀더
훼손이라기보다는 일부은 상반기 최대
승자에 대한 비중 정상화 정도라고
보고 있다 이야기를 했고요. 수급
측면에서는 월말 월투를 지나고 난
뒤에 리밸런십시 부담이 완화될
가능성이 있고 이격도 측면에서도 7월
상순 이후쯤 단기 과열 부담이 완화될
수 있어 보인다.라는 이야기를
했습니다.
오른쪽 패 먼저 봐 주시면 삼성전자와
SK닉스의 30 이격도라고 볼 수가
있는데요. 아직 이격이 벌어져 있긴
한데 이번 달 초에 비해 6월 달 초
이야기를 하는 거죠. 6월 달 초에
비해 많이 완화되고 있고 전자의
이격이 좀 더 빨리 좁혀진 상황이라고
합니다. 30일 이격도가 크게
벌어지면 대로 주가 조정이 있었다라고
하고요. 확실히 삼성전자가
하이닉스보다 최근에 주가가 많이
약하게 됐고 상승할 때도 덜 올랐기
때문에 거의 뭐 30일 이격까지
내려와 있는 상황이고요. 그리고
오른쪽은 SK닉스인데 어 뭐 개별
종목 레버리지 ETF 나온 이후에
홀로 쪽 많이 강했었고 또 ADR
상장 모멘텀을 받으면서 어 주가가
상대적으로 많이 강했었는데 지금
32격도가 아직 좀 벌어져 있는
상황이다 볼 수가 있어서 뭐 기술적
분석으로 연근이 말한 걸로만 보면
현재는 삼성전자가 더 유리한 구간일
수가 있겠다는 런 생각이 들고요.
어제 일단 주가 흐름 자체는 전자가
상당히 상대적으로 좀 강했었던 모습이
나타나기도 했었던 거 같습니다.
그리고 왼쪽 표는 외국인의 매도가 좀
계속해서 강하게 나오고 있는데요.
아까 말씀해 주셨지만 뭐 100조원
넘게 매도가 나오고 있고 뭐 149조
정도 어 매도세가 나오고 있습니다.
그리고 오른쪽은 코스피 연기금
매수인데요. 코스 연기금에서도
한 4월 달부터는 계속 매도
오이더라고요. 그리고
어 지금 연기금의 코스 그 한국 주식
노출 동안 29% 정도 되는 걸로
알고 있는데요.
어 뭐 여러 가지 조건을 따져서 한
26.8%까지 8%까지 낮춰야
된다라고 늘었는데 그러면 한 40조
정도를 매도해야 된다라고 하고요.
근데 아까 말씀해 주셨지만 외국인의
그런 매도 폭탄에도 불구하고 지수는
펀더 따라서 위로 올라갔었잖아요.
그리고 연기금이 이걸 시장에 영향을
줄만큼 뭐 하루에 10조 뭐 이렇게
매도하는 것도 아니고 뭐 조단위
정도에 많이 팔아야 이제 조단위로
매도할 텐데 그 정도로 시장이 크게
흔들릴 가능성은 없지 않을까 그런
생각을 가지고 있습니다.
자, 삼성전자 하이닉스 요렇게
나오는데 과거의 패턴으로 보면 항상
삼성전자가 먼저 고점이 나와서
됐잖아요. 음 2017년 11월에
삼성전자 고점 나오고 18년 5월
달에 하이닉스 고점 나왔고 21년에도
21년 1월에 삼성전자 고점 나오고
4월에 하이닉스 고점 나왔고 그래서
삼성전자가 계속 고점을 갱신을 하면
그러면음 하이넥스 아직은 괜찮겠네
하면 되는 거고 3개월이 지났는데
하이닉스는 고점을 갱신하고 있는데
전자가 갱신 못 하고 지부진하면 아
이제는 하이닉스도 날려되나? 예.
그렇게 생각하면 되지 않겠는가? 과거
사례만 보면 그런 생각을 했었고
하이닉스는 마이크론의 고점은 거의 뭐
비슷하게 나오긴 합니다.
음. 마이크론의 고점이 제일 마지막에
나오는 경우 많았었는데
그렇게 참고를 하시고 이번에도 어 또
7월 말에 워낙 좋은 실적 발표가
예정되 있기 때문에네음
당연히 이제 실적을 보고 가면 고점을
두 회사 모두다 고점을 갱신할
가능성이 높다라고는 봐야 되는데 항상
시장이 똑똑하기 때문에 만약에 방금
말씀드렸던 그런 어 현상이 나타나면
아 좀 이제는 좀 줄여야 되나 그런
생각을 좀 하셔도 될 거 같습니다.
어 그리고 연기금도
매도가 나왔는데 최근에 9,300
갔을 때는이 국내 비중이 전체 자산에
한 1600조가 넘는 자산에서
30%가 아마 넘었었을 거예요. 네.
>> 예. 30%가 넘다 보니까 그 전략적
자산 배분에 있어서 플 플러스
마이너스 5%인가 그래서 29%까지는
괜찮은데 30 넘어가면 그거는 어쩔
수 없이 또 팔아야 되니까 그래서
미리 좀 매도 나온 거
어 21년도에도 그랬지만 외국인
연기금 다 매도하는데 시장이 어 안
빠졌었어요.
그때는 제로 금리도 만들어 줬었고
미국 시장 자체가 계속 강하다 보니까
미국 시장하고 계속 글로벌 시장하고
비교를 하면서 매도서에도 불구하고 안
빠졌으면 돼. 시장이 이제 꺾이게
되면 그동안에이
매물을이
받아왔던
그 투자자들이 마지막에 좀 포머로
들어오신 분들이 많다 보니까 시장이
꺾이면 또 거기에 가장 민감하게 또
반응을 하시거든요.
꺾였네.
그러면서 이제 시장이 왈칵 쏟아지는
그런 호스도 나왔기 때문에
계속
미국 시장 계속 모니터링 좀 하면서
자 그다음에 리포터가 하나 더 있는데
명백한 공급자 우위 시장 하나 김민경
연구원 자료
리포트가 있었는데요. 수주 공시도
나왔었습니다. 그래서 일단 내용을 좀
보면 타겟 프라이스를 300만 원까지
올려 잡았다고 합니다. 그래서 타겟
프라이스를 굉장히 높게 잡은 거
같고요. 목표 주가는 28년 예상
EPS의 타겟 멀티플 60배를
적용해서 표가 산정했고요.
원래이 정도 시기에는 사실 28년에
실적을 끌어다가 리포트를 쓰는 경우
그 타겟 프라이스를 산정하는 경우는
많이 못 본 거 같은데요.
연구이 봤을 때 아마 28년까지 이익
성장이 좀 명백히 나올 거다라고
생각을 하기 때문에 28년 실까지
끌어온 거 같고요.
그래서 이비의 28년 예상 대비
40% 프리미엄을 적용했다라고
합니다. 이비뎀보다도
더 [콧방귀] 높은 밸류를 주겠다라는
이야기인 거 같고요. 예의 데이터
센터 수요 확대를 중심으로 MLCC나
프리치 BJ 공급 부족이 치화가 되고
있고 28년까지 가파는 실적성장이
지속될 것으로 전망을 했습니다.
글로벌 MSCC 업체들의 AI 서브용
생산 능력 확대는 범형 MLCC 생산
능력 족를 가속화하고 있다라고
하고요. 데이터 센터형 초소형이나
초고용량 MLC 시수에는 글로벌
탑티어 업체에 집중될 것으로 판단을
한다. 그리고 플리치 BJ도 제한적인
공급 환경 속에서 가격 협상력이 좀
강화되고 있다라고 하고요. 네트워크
서버양 매출 비중 확대와 전 제품은
판가 상승으로 수익성이 좀 빠르게
계산되고 있다고 합니다. 최근 실리콘
캐패시터나 수동 소자가 내장된
인베디드 플래시 BJ 수요가
증가하면서 고수익 제품 비중이 확대가
되고 있고 그리고 IT 부품 업체
대비 프리미엄 밸루에이션 적용이
가능하다라는 이야기를 했습니다.
고부가 MCC 우려가지고 확대
중이라고 하는데요. 삼성전기는 금일
약 4,500억 정도의 규모의 MSC
단일 공급 계약을 공시를 했었고이는
27년 AI 데이터 센터형 초소형이나
초고양량 MSC 공개약으로 파악이
된다라고 합니다.
27년 공급 물량을 현 시점에서 장기
계약했다는 점은 AI의 서버양 고부가
MS 수요가 급증하는 가운데 OX4의
중장기 MSC 수급 무려가 좀 커지고
있다라고 볼 수가 있겠고요. MCC가
AI 서버 핵심 부품으로 자리 잡고
있음을 시세 시사한다. 어 특히 뭐
서버용 쪽이 초공영량이나 어 초소형
쪽은 전기나 무라타가 아예 잡고 있는
시장이기 때문에 아예 다른 업체는 못
들어보네. 지금 기술력이 부족해서
그래서이 기업들이 어 점유 확대하고이
파일을 다 가져갈 텐데 이렇게 되면은
제품 믹스가 나타날 거고 마진이 더
올라갈 가능성이 매우 높다 보는게
맞는 거 같고요. 그다음 플리치 PJ
이야기 했는데요. 우후적 시장 환경
장기와 전망입니다. AI 데이터센터
가속기와 서버시피 수요가 견조하게
지속이 되고 있다라고 하고요. 반도체
대면적화가 플리치 BJ 대면적화 그
고다층화로 이어지면서 케파로스가 어
심화되고 있다라고 합니다. 공정드가
굉장히 심하다고 들었거든요. 데이터
센터 플j의 경우이 이전에 이비된
실적학교에서도 거기서 이제 대표님이
어 그런 코멘트를 한 적이 있었는데
뭐 뭐 네덕이나 이노택 삼성전기도 뭐
마찬가지인 상황이겠죠. 글로벌 기파
업체들의 대규모 증설에도 실제적 공급
증가부는 예상보다 제한적일 수가
있겠다. 그래서 탑티어 기판 업체들은
고객사가 선수금을 어 선별적으로
수령하고 있는 것으로 파악된다라고
하고요. 타이탄 수급 환경으로 인해
서버뿐만 아니라 PC나 전작용 플리치
페이지의 입판가도 어 빠르게 상승하고
있다라고 합니다. 그래서 이런 수익성
계 선세가 단기적인게 아니라 좀
장기간 이어질 가능성이 높다 이야기를
했습니다. 메모리랑 좀 비슷한 거
같아. 메모리가 처음에 HBM이
어 주류로 잡기 시작하면서 케파
잠식을 많이 하기 시작했잖아요. 근데
뭐 MNCC도 그렇고 지금 플레이치
PJ도 그렇고 둘 다 마찬가지인 거
같아요. 그 중국이나 대만 업체들의
그 MSCC 2티어 3티어 업체들
거기조차도 지금 가격 인상을 하고
있잖아요. 근데 그게 삼성전기나
이비니 이제 저부가나 중적가의 MCC
개파를 전부 다이 서버 쪽이나 전장
쪽으로 돌리면서 그 부족한 부분을
밑에 있는 기업들이 먹고 있는
거거든요. 낙스 효과로. 그래서 그런
부분을 확인할 [콧방귀] 수가 있고
또 플리치 BJ도 마찬가지 저희 최
고성능 플리치 BJ의 경우는 전기나
그리고 이비덴이 하다 보니까 나머지
파일을 또 밑에 있는 어 대덕 전자
그리고
코리아 서키트 이런 기업들이 또 먹는
거기 때문에 그런 부분에서 수혜가
지금 여러 산업꾼으로 좀 펼쳐지고
있다라는 생각이 들고요. 실적 추위가
좀 계속 올라가는 거 같아요. 제가
MSCC 사업부의 이익을 추정해 봤을
때 사실 내년 이익이 한 2조 정도
나올 것으로 추정을 했었거든요. 근데
지금 추정치가 거의 뭐 2조
5천억까지 올라왔습니다. 제가 계산한
거는 MLCC 계단 가격을 한 6원
정도 6.6원 원 정도 성을 했던 거
같은데요. 아마 2조 5,000원까지
가려면 이게 7원이 넘어야 될 것
같긴 한데 그러면 올해 1분기보다
40% 가격 인상을 가정해야
되거이었기
때문에. 그럼 뭐 그렇게 될 수도
있겠다. 왜냐면 지금은 아직 그
5원이라는게 가격 인상분이 아예 반영
안 된 수거든. 일본 계실적은. 근데
이제 인상하기 시작한다라고 하면은
과거에도 40%씩은 올라갔었어요. 그
초호환기에는. 근데 그 초호환기보다도
더 좋다라는 거죠. 지금은. 왜냐면
이전 초호환기는 모바일 PC였다면
지금은 데이터 센터, 전장, AI
이쪽이기 때문에 그런 모바일 PC에
들어가는 수요도 좋았을 때 40%가
올라갔는데이
지금은 그 이상이겠죠. 그러면 40%
이상 올라갈 것을 가정하고 연구원들이
추정을 하고 있는게 아닌가 그런
생각이 듭니다. 내년 전사 실적을
보면 매출 16조 전망되고 있고요.
영업 이익이 한 3조 4천억 정도
전망이 되고 있는 거 같습니다.
오른쪽은 미래세 층권 자료를 제가
가져왔는데요. 사이클 구조는 동일한데
수요 성격은 단기에서 좀 구조적으로
변화되고 있는 거 같다는 전망입니다.
수요 성격이라고 해서 여기 아래 좀
코멘트를 적어 놨는데요. 17년도
이야기를 하는 거 같은데 스마트폰
주도 단기 급등이 있었던 시기고
지금은 어 AI 서버주도 기 때문에
완만하고 지속적으로 올라갈 가능성이
높다라는 이야기를 했습니다.
그래서 현재 시점을 보면 17년
사이클의
어 사이클 정도로 좀 보고 있는데
추가적인 ASP 상승 사이클도 지속
가능하다라고 보는 거 같습니다.
그래서 17년도 사례가 왼쪽에
있는데요.
야가오가 2017년 9월 달에 가격
인상을 시작을 했었고 17년 11월
달에 또 가격을 올렸고 17년 말에도
좀 올렸다라고 볼 수가 있는데 이렇게
지금도 마찬가지거든요. 그 야가오나
중가 저가하는 MCC 업체들이 가격을
먼저 올리기 시작을 했거든요.
그다음에 이제 전기나 이비의
고부가까지 올라가는 흐름이 나타날
건데 그런 부분이 올해에도 내년에도
이어질 가능성이 있다라고 보는 거
같습니다. 그래서 결국 얘기하고 싶은
거는 또 그런 거죠. 과거는
경기 사이클에 만 경기 사이클에 따라
움직이는 스마트폰 PC 수요였다면
이번에는 경기 사이클과 크게 연관이
없는 B2B 사이클이기 때문에이
사이클 자체가 좀 더 장기화 될 수
있다라고 보는 거 같고요. 그다음
페이지에는 카테고리별 5단기 정성
평가에 따른 타이트닝강도 추인데 첫
번째가 프리치 PJ 그다 HPM
메모리 기판 이런 쪽을 이야기를 하고
있고요. 여기서 이제 병목 병목
병목으로 돼 있는 것만 보면 좋을 거
같은데요. 가장 병목은 역시나 HPM
주황색으로 칠해져 있고요. 그다음은
플리시 BJ랑 MLCC가 주황색으로
두 개씩 칠해져 있는데
FC BJ와 MSC를 다하는 회사는
글로벌하게 삼성 전기밖에 없습니다.
>> 그래서 그런 부분에서 메리트가 확실히
>> 있는 거 같고요. 그 실제로도
보면이 오른쪽 표 봐 주시면 메모리가
이제 전에도 비슷한 차를 보여 드린
적이 있는데 베라루빈에서
베라루빈이 이제 GB 300 대비
본코스트 비교인데 각 그 부품별로
얼마나 이제 본코스트가 이전 대비
많이 증가하냐를 보여주는 표인데 뭐
메모리는 뭐 다섯 배 이상이고요.
그다음 PCB는 한네 배, MSC도
네배, 플래시피 한 두 배 정도
증가할 것으로 지금 전망이 되고
있습니다.
[목을 가다듬음]
그래서이 빨간색이
돈코스트가 많이 증가하는
기준으로 주가가 가장 센 거 같아요.
메모리가 일단 가장 세고 그다음
PCB, MLCC, 플리치피 이런
것들이 있는데 확실히 이런 기업들이
주가가 좋죠. 뭐 신택, 대덕, 삼성
전기 이런 기업들이 상대적으로
타소부장 대비 많이 강한 편인데
그쪽으로의 쇼티지가 가장 강하다라는
것을 알 수가 있는 거 같습니다.
표 좋네요. 보니까
>> 하택 고리별 다섯 단계 정성 평가에
따른 타이닝 강도 추의해 가지고
26, 27, 28년도
>> 이게 병목인지 병목이 더 강화되는지
요렇게 나왔잖아 있고 오른쪽에도
베라루 관련돼서 뭐 이렇게 나오는데
근데 어제 워맨신박 신문일다가이
MLCC 전체 시장 규모가 한 어느
정도 되는지 알아요?
아,
>> 우리가 뭔가 좋다고 하면
>> 그 시장 규모를 알아야 되잖아요.
그래서 뭐
>> 내년 내오년에 뭐 템이 얼마까지
증배할 수 있다. 뭐 이렇게 하는데
>> 예.
그래서 시장 규모가
어느 정도 들고 반도체만 하더라도
메모리가 한 200조 시장이었다가
지금 뭐 거의 뭐 100조 시장으로
크게 가격이 뛴 것도 있긴 하지만
됐는데
MNCC가
>> 예
>> 제가 어제 그 몸의 심박 읽으면서
>> 말씀드릴게요. AI가 MLCC 시장
성장의 핵심 동력으로 자리 잡으면서
시장 규모도 빠르게 확대할 전망이다.
시장 조사 업체 비즈니스 리서치
인사이츠에 따르며 글로벌 MLCC
시장 규모는 올해
>> 예
>> 42억 7천만 달러
>> 6조야
>> 6조
>> 그리고 2030년에
>> 55억 6천만 달러
>> 2030년 돼야 8조시죠. 음.
>> 근데 그게 삼성전기 26년 매출
컴포넌트 매출만 봐도 6조인데
>> 그래서 근데 컴포넌트에는
그 플리치비 그 PCB 들어가는 거
아니야? 아니면 그 패키지 쪽에
들어갔
>> 어 패키지 쪽에 들어갔고
>> MLCC MLCC만 지금 네네
>> 네
>> 거기 들어간다고
>> 컴퍼넌트 CC만
>> 어 컴퍼넌트 그 이거 보면서
>> 아니 MLCC 시장 규모가 이것밖에
안 되나?
>> 요거는 어제 읽으면서
>> 확인해 봐야 되겠다.
>> 2035년 돼야 80억 9천만
달러까지 성장하는 거죠. 한번 조금
물어보세요.
>> 네.
그래서 너무 템이 작다 그러면서
업체들도 가격 인상에 나섰다. 세계
1위 MSC 일부 무라타의 고용량
고부가 같이 제품인 40조
마이크로패럿 제품 가격이 한 개당
0.2 위안에서 0.65 6억
전기도 5월 이후 주요 제품 가격이
인상된 것으로 알려졌니다.
기관 다 차가 심하네요.
어떤 데는
모더 인텔리전스는 318.7억
달러라고 얘기를 하고 있고요.
>> 저도 320억 달러
>> 네. 그리고 마화라고 계산하면은 거의
20조부터 49조 정도
>> 예 그러네요.
>> 한 20조부터 49조
>> 예 그렇습니다.
>> 왜냐면 전기가 한 글로벌처면 2,
30% 정도 되고 근데 6조
매출이잖아요. 그리고 뭐 이비되니 한
>> 이비되니 무라타가 그보다 좀 더 큰
걸로 알고 있는데 두 개만 하쳐도 한
14조 막 16조 이렇게 될 텐데
>> 전기가 20%면 전기 매출에 곱하기
5 해 버리면 되니까
>> 그렇죠. 그럼 6조에 5, 6,
30, 30조라.
>> 그죠? 그러면이 비슷하시면 되 있는데
>> 대체로 차가 있지만 30조에서 50조
>> 30조 어 그 정도는
>> 예 맞습니다.지
>> 가끔씩 이제 기사 보다 보면
>> 예. 아, 이게 숫자가 맞나 싶을
때가 있는데.
>> 예.
>> 어제 터미네이터 영화 나온게
1984년이라고 돼 있길래 아, 요거
틀렸을 걸 94년일 걸 했는데 그거는
또 84년이 맞더라고요. [웃음]
>> 음.
아무튼 MLCC 시장 규모가 그
정도단 말이죠.
>> 예. 그리고 약간 과점화 돼 있고이
전기가 옛날에 1.5티어 정도
>> 무라타랑 아까 야교 대만 야교가 한
시장 점유일이 1등인가요?
무라타가
그래서 무라타 그다음에 야교 그다음에
우리나라 삼성전기
요렇게가 약간 위에 상위고
>> 중국 업체가 지금 약간 법용
>> MSC 막 쫓아온 거 있나요?
>> 네. 충분는 밑에요.
>> 아 밑에네
>> 10등 안에 들어가는데 완전 밑에
지금 수도 분면은 1등 몰라 다 2등
3등 약도 약효도네
더더 내려갔어요.
>> 우리가 어 주식을 항상 그 산업내의
경쟁 부도랑 그 산업의 파이는 계속
커지고 있는가 그죠.
산업의 성장성도 중요하지만
경쟁부도 항상 파악을 해야 되고
>> 알겠습니다.
그래서 제목이 명백한 아직까지는
공급자 우의 시장이다. 셀러스
마켓이다.
사람이
>> 올해 실적은 그냥 가동률 회복으로
나타나는 실적 증가고
>> 내년은 가격 인상이 나타나는 실적
>> 증가
>> 그래서 밸루에이션이 굉장히 높긴
한데요.
>> 이익을 보면 그게 설명이 된다라는
거거든요. 올해 영업이 1조
7천억인데 내년에 3조 4천억.
>> 올해도 91% 성장. 내년에 98%
성장.
>> 전망이라서
그 지금 예를 들어 100배면 내년
되면 50배로 떨어진다는 얘기 볼
수가 있잖아요. 그렇기 때문에
>> 높은 밸류를 주고도 사람들이 일단
사는 느낌.
>> 그
아마 2 3번 실정 특별한 기대할 수
있는 건 없어요. 음.
가격은 이만큼 이미 올라하고
>> 그래서 추가 상승 조정할 여유가
없고요.
>> 핵심은 잡은기입니다.
>> 잡은기보죠.
>> 잡은기인데 내년은 연간 그 공급
계약을 매겨야 돼요. 그래서 가격은
나올 수 있습니다.
>> 그래서 내년 아마 4번기 들어가면
내년 실적만 상을면 가능성이 있어요.
그래서 핵심 부분은 2, 3분기는
실적 두는 거보다 4분기.
>> 음. 음.
>> 그거는 잘 더 기대하다.
2,
>> 3분기는 숫자가 아직까지는 제대로
나오지 않을 거고 4분기부터
>> 맞아요.
>> 어. 어.
>> 좋은 거 알았네.
>> 그리고 삼성전기는
오를 때는 굉장히 폭발적으로 오르는데
>> 이거 고점에 잘못 들리면 5년 5년
보생하는 주식이에요.
>> 그래서 계속 이렇게 공부를 우리가 해
봐야 될 그렇습니다. 음.
알겠습니다. 고맙습니다. 자, 시장
시작했는데
어떻게 되고 있습니까?
>> 네, 시장 1.36%로 상승해서
출발했고요. 현재 플러스 0.89%로
소폭 하락하고 있습니다.
>> 쫙 밀렸네요.
>> 야간 선물이 어제 1.58 올랐는데
딱고 언저리에서 시작해서 살짝 지금은
매물 압박을 받고 있습니다.
>> 네.
>> 투자 동량 나옵니까?
>> 네. 잠시만요. 볼게요.
>> 외국인하고 연기검 기관 매도 뭐
이렇게 나오겠네.
>> 네. 그 현재 시장에서 외국인
3,500억 정도 매도를 하고
있고요. 그리고 코스닥도 한 1천억
정도 지금 매도가 나오네요. 외국인
>> 굉장히 좀 세게 매도가 나오고요.
>> 어 기관은 지금 6,억 정도 시장을
매수하고 있습니다. 6,500억
정도.
>> 아 매수고 어 개인 투자자분들도 팔고
있네.
>> 네.
자, 코스닥은 어떻게 해야 됩니까?
>> 네, 코스닥 시장 + 0.86%로
상승해서 출발했고요. 어, 현재
0.17%로
어, 속와 있습니다. 네. 0.8
시작해서 0.39 코스닥은 오늘 그
에코프로 형제들
>> 네. 음. 저기 유정이 있었잖아요.
>> 보니까 한 10%
>> 해당되는 유정이 있었던데
>> 좀 밀리겠네요.
>> 네. 오늘 4% 정도 밀리는데요.
어제 시간에서는 한 10% 정도 넘게
밀렸던 거 같은데요.
>> 그래도 오늘 시작하면서 조금씩
회복하고 있습니다.
>> 어제 시장에서도 2차전지 같은 별로
다 안 좋았잖아요. 약간 미리
선반영을 좀 한 건가? 음. 뭐 그런
생각도 좀 들었고요.
자, 어제는 제가 어 정권사
투자 설명회가 있어서 금만 하고
갔었는데
어제 신형은 어떻게 전망대
하셨습니까?
유리 부분.
>> 이제 둘 다 상승으로 했었습니다.
>> 어어.
아스닥, SNPB, 필반 다 뭐 상승
전망하셨겠네요.
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 오늘은 어떻게 됩니까?
오늘도 둘 다 상승으로 하겠습니다.
>> 오늘도 둘 다 상승으로.
>> 우리 프로가 SP 500 나스타 둘
다 맞춘다고 고생이 많아요.
일반은 어떻게 됩니까?
>> 상승을 하겠습니다.
>> 미국은 다 상승.
>> 예.
>> 그다음에 국내는
어제 국내는 뭐라고 했어요?
>> 저 코스타는 음봉으로 얘기했습니다.
>> 음봉. 어제 음봉이네.
>> 했습니다.
>> 승률 보니까 열님이 해 주시는 승률도
보니까 쭉 올라오고
>> 음.
>> 오과장도 쭉 올라갔더라고.
>> 아. 네.
>> 자, 오늘은 어떻게 돼요?
>> 어, 코스타는 여전히 음봉으로
나왔어요.
>> 코스닥은 여전히 음봉.
코스피는 어떻게 됩니까?
스피 차트 한번 봐야 되겠다.
어제 못 했던 차트 분석 지금
오늘 되게 애매한 날인 거 같은데
미국에서 반도체가 많이 올랐는데
마이크론이 조금 부진했어 가지고
요즘 코스피 맞추려면 뭐 무조건
삼성전자 하이닉스
그니까 50% 이상을 차지하다 보니까
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 얘네도 분석해야 되.
>> 근데 약간 투자들이 의심을 이제 좀
하기 시작한 거 같아서 반도체에 대한
메모리 반도체에 대한
>> 의심.
>> 네.
>> 음.
>> 뭐 어제도 말씀드렸지만 시장 급락
금요일에 했었을 때
>> 그러고 이제 월요일에 원래 같은
흐름이면 반등 나올 때 메모리가 제일
세야 되는데
>> 메모리가 4%씩 부러졌었잖아요.
>> 어.
시장은 플러스가 났는데
>> 어
>> 그런 걸 보면
>> 이전 흐름과 많이 달라졌다 생각이 좀
>> 그냥 그 감으로 보는게 있잖아
힘이 좀 약해진 느낌인데 그게 좀
들어서
어제 좀 일단 다 조금씩 반등했기
때문에 오늘은 조정이 나오잖아봉해
보겠습니다. 어 보내운
그러게 지금 삼성전자 차트 보고
있는데 어 아주 센 차트는 아니네.
네.
>> 그죠?
>> 네.
>> 그리고 하이닉스는 6월 25일 날
298만 7,000원 고점 찍어 놓고
지금 265만 3,000원 요러고
있고 약간 미국 시장이 어떻게
되는가? 7월 초에 어떻게 되는가
눈치 보고
>> 어 가겠다 약간 요런 느낌
>> 있고 어제 미국 10년물 국제 금리가
또 4.4를
>> 넘어서 가지고
>> 이런 부분들은 좀 약간 심리에 영향을
줄 것 같고요. 고용 잘 나왔고
아까 말씀드린 대로 7월 10날
전으로 해 가지고 또 CPI 발표될
건데 CP 뭐 떨어질 것 같지는 않고
전쟁은 이제는 뭐 관심은 별로 없지만
>> 예
>> 그
저 뭐 종전 이것도 보면
아닌 거 같은거든
>> 계속 끌고 갈 것 같습니다. 트럼프
대통령 입장에서는이
육가로
초야 금리가 떨어지고
그러다 보니까 무조건 휴전 60일 어
이렇게 해서 호르무저에 지금 갇혀
있는 대협에 갇혀 있는 유조선들 빨리
좀
오게끔 만들려고 하는데
이런이 혁명 수비대도 만만치 않아요
>> 만만치 않습니다
>> 참
계속 거기에 하는 노이즈는 계속
나오긴 나올 것 같아. 단지 어 처음
이런 전쟁 터졌을 때에 비해서는
사람들이 이제 거기에 익숙해지고
있다는 거. 대단한 위협을 보지 않고
있다는 거. 그런 부분들
긍정적이긴 한데
그리고 시장이 아직까지는 뭐 약한
시장이 아니기 때문에 어 수납면은
어디로 올 건가 그것도 계속 지켜봐야
되고
반도체가 쉬면 또 뭐가 올라오는지
알겠습니다. 겠습니다.
자,
오늘 저희가 준비한 순서는
여기까지고요. 아, 참 5일차
저거 룰브레이크 님이 5일차 저거
음봉양분 다 맞추셨죠. 어제 메시막
댓글에 올려 놓으신 거 제가 봤었는데
룰브레이커 님은 어 전화 주셔 가지고
책 받아 가시거나 뭐 다 첫 번 다
맞추셨으니까 내일 저녁에 진행되나
월간전마
참석권을 또 드리도록 하겠습니다.
오셔 가지고 책 받아 오셔도 될 거
같습니다. 네. 그러면 오늘 7월
1일
>> 아 지수 맞추기 왔다 갔다.
>> 음
>> 자 지수 맞추기 6월 달 지수 맞추기
상점자 발표를 해 드리겠습니다.
보니까 헤님
8,555라고
예상을 해 주셨고 아 6월 종가는
8,476으로
거의 껌지처럼 딱 그대로 끝났다죠.
예.
>> 8,55 얘기해 주셨는데 1등입니다.
2등이 채부자님 8,500 예상해
주셨고 5차 23.5 잠깐만 그러면
최부자님이 1등 아니에요?
>> 8,476.48로
끝났는데
>> 예
>> 8,500으로 예상하실
최부장님이 1등이구 그죠? 2등이
8,55님이시고
오뚜기 님이 8,700
8,700이 200이셨죠?
그렇다. 그죠?
이 낙관적인 전망이 우세했었네요.
뭡니까? 5월 달랑이
4월, 5월 워낙 이제 급등을 하다
보니까 전체적으로 참가자 47분
중에서
8,476보다
높을 거다라고 예상하신 분이
36번입니다.
소수 의견의 정확성 실제 종가의
건접하기이
[목을 가다듬음] 세명 제어졌고
최저값은 6,950일
얘기하신 분이 있었고 11800
전망하신 분들도 계셨습니다.
예. 최부자님, 해 님, 오뚜기 님
축하드리고요. 최근에 나온 진짜
부자, 가짜 부자 사경인 회계사님의
책을 선물해 드리도록 하겠습니다.
자, 7월 전망도 예, 적어 주시길
바라겠습니다.
자, 7월 전막 쭉 올라오고 있는데
지금 보니까 9,500 11,500
1600 9,00 9,450 8,
9,800
8, 초도 많으시고 8, 중반 9천만
이렇게 많이 전망을 해 주시고
계십니다. 최근에 좋은 책이 계속
저한테 배달이 되고 있습니다. 예.
할아버지의 두 번째 책도 나오고요.
>> 음.
>> 그러니까 적극적으로 예, 참여해
주시면 고맙겠습니다.
>> 네. 오늘 채슬리 모닝 브리퍼 7월
1일 순서는 여기까지 하겠습니다.
오늘 하루도 하루도 건강하시고 행복한
하루 되시길 바라겠습니다.
고맙습니다.
합니다.